l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement
la première d'entre elles va être posée
par Monsieur Franck alizio pour le
rassemblement national
merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie monsieur le ministre le
spectre de la crise financière de 2008
est-il à nouveau à en train de roder
autour de l'Europe et de la France trois
banques ou Atlantique ont fait faillite
en quelques jours dans la 16e et la 21e
banque américaine la Silicone Valley
Bank c'est en effet effondré en 48
heures vendredi 15 ans après la faille
de Lemon Brother les États-Unis n'ont
visiblement rien appris aussi peu alors
certes en Europe nous avons appris les
banques européennes sont depuis la crise
de 2008 dotée de règles prudentielles
plus strictes et vous nous avez enfermé
encore hier que cette panique bancaire
aux États-Unis était une crise lointaine
des cas isolés
êtes-vous sûr monsieur le ministre que
toutes les banques européennes ont les
reins solides et un bilan sain prenons
le Crédit Suisse par exemple cette
grande institution historique que de nos
voisins helvétiques connaît de profondes
difficultés et pourtant le cri du Suisse
est à nos portes au cœur de la finance
européenne c'est surtout une banque
systémique qui remplirait tous les
critères du Maillon Faible ma question
monsieur le ministre concerne le risque
d'effet dominos de propagation via des
banques européennes qui seraient
identifiées comme des maillons faibles
par les marchés avez-vous monsieur le
ministre une vue d'ensemble est précise
de la solidité financière de ces banques
européennes pouvez-vous nous garantir
monsieur le ministre qu'il n'y a et
qu'il n'y aura aucun risque de manque de
liquidité et d'insolabilité pour nos
banques françaises dans les prochaines
semaines je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
et Monsieur le Député Franck alizio il
n'y a pas de risque sur le système
bancaire français
et comparaison n'est pas raison
la SVB la Silicon Valley banque avait
trois caractéristiques 1 a été exposée à
un seul secteur d'activité le secteur
détectologie 2 elle avait comme seul et
unique placement les bons du Trésor
américain ce qui fait que lorsque les
taux ont remonté le placement était
moins positif les épargnants ont retiré
leurs avoir et la banque s'est retrouvée
à court de liquidité 3 l'été soumises
qu'à la supervision du superviseur de
San Francisco un superviseur régional
puisque je le rappelle seul 13 banques
américaines sur les 3500 banques
américaines sont soumises aux règles de
supervision de balles 3 là où 400
banques européennes sont soumises aux
règles de supervision de balles 3
c'est-à-dire les règles les plus
strictes le système bancaire français
lui c'est un système universel avec six
grandes banques qui représentent plus de
90% des dépôts des épargnants des dépôts
des entreprises un système universel et
un système diversifié où chacune de ces
banques a déplacement qui sont très
diversifiés et avec des ratios de
liquidités des ratios de solvabilité qui
sont parmi les meilleurs au monde je
rappelle que les bancs françaises depuis
la crise que vous rappelez à juste titre
de 2008 ont 1550 milliards d'euros de
fonds propres supplémentaires
disponibles pour assurer le ratio de
solvabilité donc je veux vous rassurer
et à travers vous rassurer tous nos
compatriotes le système bancaire
français et solide et il n'y a pas de
risque sur les banques françaises
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président Mattei pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre
la réforme des retraites que nous allons
finaliser cette semaine après des mois
de concertation et de travail est à nos
yeux essentiels et nécessaires
il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de sauver
notre régime par répartition quasiment
unique au monde pour la solidarité qu'il
crée entre les générations
sans cette réforme les 1,5 cotisants
pour un retraité en 2035 ne suffiront
plus pour pérenniser le système la
baisse attendue du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités sera inacceptable le défi site
cumulé laissez à nos enfants sera de
plus de 150 milliards alors oui la
réforme que nous portons est avant tout
une réforme de responsabilité vis-à-vis
des retraités d'aujourd'hui et des
jeunes générations qui n'ont pas apporté
la charge des inconsciences passées en
outre elle était allée dans le temps
pour être plus acceptable madame la
Première ministre nous devons aussi
c'est notre rôle rassurer les Français
oui nous leur demandons de travailler
plus longtemps mais nous devons aussi
leur donner des garanties c'est ce que
nous souhaitons entendre aujourd'hui
ainsi qu'en est-il des mesures pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt la
prise en compte de la pénalité de la
pénibilité des pénibilités derais-je
dire est-elle garantie en particulier
pour les carrières
la situation des femmes est-elle enfin
améliorée après toutes ces réformes
qu'ils ont ignorées vont-elles être
enfin rétablies dans leurs droits à
savoir une retraite digne vous savez à
quel point le groupe démocrate y a
travaillé enfin allons-nous améliorer le
taux d'emploi des seigneurs dans deux
tiers ne travaillaient plus pour mettre
ainsi un terme à ce gâchis humain tous
ces points madame première ministre sont
l'assurance du respect de notre contrat
social je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Jean-Paul Mattei
nous arriverons dans quelques jours au
terme d'un long processus de travail de
concertation et de débats
il y a un an le président de la
République s'est présenté au suffrage
des Français en portant l'engagement
d'une réforme pour garantir l'avenir de
nos retraites par répartition à
l'automne 2022 avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du socle nous avons
lancé des concertations avec les
organisations syndicales patronales et
les groupes parlementaires elles nous
ont permis de présenter un projet de loi
enrichi par leur propositions et je sais
combien avec vos collègues de la
majorité monsieur le Président Mattei
vous y avez contribué depuis le débat
parlementaire se poursuit au Sénat le
texte a été discuté jusqu'au bout et
adopter en fin de semaine dernière
l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà consacré
plus de temps à débattre de ce projet
que lors des deux précédentes réforme
des retraites même si l'obstruction
organisée a accaparer le débat
mais mesdames mais mesdames et messieurs
les députés
mais mesdames et messieurs les députés
dans cette assemblée une majorité existe
qui croit au travail y compris au
travail des seniors
une majorité existe qui croit au système
de retraite par répartition et qui veut
garantir à notre jeunesse qu'elle en
bénéficiera
une majorité existe qui refuse de
financer les retraites par plus d'impôts
plus de charges et moins de pension
une majorité existe qui croit que ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
devront partir plutôt à la retraite une
majorité existe qui veut mieux protéger
celles et ceux qui ont un métier
difficile et oui monsieur le Président
Mattei permettre à ceux qui ont été
usés par le travail de partir plus tôt à
la retraite
une majorité existe qui sait que la
plupart des régimes spéciaux n'est plus
justifiés qu'il faut les fermer une
majorité existe qui pense qu'il faut à
augmenter les petites pensions des
futurs retraités comme des retraités
actuels
une majorité existe qui veut réduire les
inégalités de pension entre les femmes
et les hommes une majorité existe qui
n'a pas peur des réformes même un
populaire quand elles sont nécessaires
une majorité existe qui fera toujours
passer la responsabilité avant
l'affichage la posture ou les petits
calculs du coût d'après
une majorité existe qui ne se laisse
intimider ni par les insultes ni par les
menaces ni par le vandalisme sur les
permanences
une majorité existe pour garantir
aujourd'hui l'avenir de nos retraites et
pour assumer demain des désaccords ou
des oppositions franche sur d'autres
sujets la commission mixte paritaire se
réunira demain sur notre projet pour les
retraites vous serez ensuite conduit à
vous exprimer sur la réforme des
retraites pas sur un soutien au
gouvernement mais sur ce projet sur ce
projet seulement et ce projet nous
pouvons en être fiers et je dis bien
nous car il a été considérablement
enrichi améliorée compléter par des
propositions des partenaires sociaux de
la majorité comme des besoins
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
pleinement engagés pour que dans les
prochains jours une majorité vote la
réforme des retraites je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard le seul
pour le groupe socialiste
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues
refusé de discuter c'est faire des
Français les victimes d'une absence de
dialogue ces mots sont les vôtres madame
la Première ministre prononcée ici même
le 11 octobre dernier l'ensemble des
syndicats s'opposent à votre projet de
réforme des retraites le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites indique
qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence plus de 65%
des Français et 80% des actifs sont
hostiles à cette réforme et à votre
projet de recul de la légal à 64 ans la
retraite à 1200 euros pour tous on le
sait maintenant grâce à nos collègues
c'est un mirage de plus les femmes
seraient les premières victimes de cette
réforme injuste
alors qu'il existe des mesures
alternatives pour protéger et augmenter
les ressources de notre système de
retraite l'augmentation du SMIC
l'augmentation des salaires des femmes
ou comme nos voisins espagnols l'ont
déjà décidé une mise à contribution des
plus fortunés d'entre nous ou encore une
augmentation de la CSG sur les
dividendes mais votre gouvernement
s'obstine à repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite alors que les évidences sont là
alors que le bon sens démocratique
devrait inviter à écouter nos
concitoyens fortement mobilisés contre
cette réforme vous semblez vous boucher
des oreilles en attendant que la tempête
passe mais en bons cynôme marin je me
permets de vous prodiguer un conseil
ballotté par les flots les marins savent
très bien que pour revenir au port il
faut écouter la mer il faut la connaître
écoutez écoutez madame la Première
ministre écoutez vos concitoyens qui
défilent chaque semaine dans nos rues
écouter entendez et dialoguer avec leur
représentants avec les acteurs syndicaux
comme vous madame la Première ministre
je crois que refuser de discuter c'est
faire des Français des victimes à
l'heure ma question est simple quand
allez-vous écouter les français pour
éviter le naufrage démocratique quand
allez-vous retirer ce funeste projet de
loi pour reprendre la discussion
notamment avec les partenaires sociaux
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail de l'insertion et du
plein emploi merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le député le
sol vous avez dit monsieur le député que
pour retourner au port il faut écouter
la mer mais pour atteindre le port il
faut avoir un cap et le cap nous l'avons
le cap c'est ramener le système de
retraite à l'équilibre parce que vous le
savez le système de retraite est
déficitaire nous le répéterons jusqu'au
bout du débat et même après nous avons
un système qui est structurellement
déficitaire avec 12 milliards et demi
d'euros de déficit en 2027 avec 13
milliards et demi en 2030 avec 20
milliards d'euros de déficit en 2035 si
nous ne faisons rien comme vous le
proposez monsieur le député c'est 150
milliards d'euros de dettes accumulées
c'est un une baisse des pensions pour
les retraités actuels c'est un
décrochage du niveau de vie des
retraités par rapport au reste de la
population vous dites monsieur le député
il n'y a pas de débat il y a eu du débat
du débat de la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales il y a eu du
débat au Sénat le Sénat a voté le texte
dans son intégralité le Sénat a voté
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
et s'il n'y a pas eu assez de débat
l'assemblée c'est responsabilité c'est
la responsabilité de la coalition autour
de la France insoumise que d'avoir
pratiqué l'obstruction pour cacher ses
divisions c'est vous qui avez fait le
choix de bloquer le débat et de ne pas
assumer cette responsabilité monsieur le
député vous dites que il faudrait rien
faire ou vous dites plus exactement il y
a d'autres solutions on les connaît vous
êtes solutions des impôts encore des
impôts toujours des impôts comme c'est
augmenter les impôts était la solution
augmenter les impôts c'est la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat c'est la perte de la
compétitivité c'est du chômage en plus
et c'est la faillite de la France
Monsieur le Député finalement ce que
vous nous proposez c'est une alternative
mortifère la baisse des retraites ou la
faillite du pays nous nous avons fait le
choix de la responsabilité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le seul monsieur le ministre et
madame la Première ministre face à votre
surdité nous nous saisirons de tous les
moyens constitutionnels pour dire non à
votre réforme
c'est bon merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le Président
chassen pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre le peuple
vous signifie depuis des semaines son
refus de votre effort injuste des
retraites cette mobilisation ne faiblit
pas au Parlement l'opposition est-elle
jusque dans vos rangs que vous avez pris
la lourde responsabilité de passer en
force ce fut d'abord le choix d'un bel
effet SS rectificatif qui limite le
temps du débat par l'article 47 1 de
notre Constitution ensuite le refus
d'ouvrir le maximum d'heures de débat
dans l'hémicycle ce fut encore
l'utilisation du vote bloqué au Sénat et
c'est toujours la menace du 49.3 pour
clore une séquence désastreuse jamais
jamais un gouvernement n'aura usé d'un
tel entêtement pour l'obstruction
démocratique
vous avez affaibli votre légitimité
démocratique et du même coup avait
marqué votre réforme du saut de
l'inégitimité les débats ont permis de
mettre à jour son inutilité et son
injustice mais aussi les mensonges les
plus flagrants les 1200 euros pour
lesquels ils partirent de millions et
finira 13000 les carrières longues dans
le flou masque l'inépsie de votre choix
la capitalisation qu'un amendement de la
droite sénatoriale a fait rentrer par la
fenêtre ajoutons à cela le mépris du
président de la République opposant une
fin de non-recevoir aux organisations
syndicales qui sollicitaient en urgence
de le rencontrer il est des victoires
qui sonnent comme des défaites de
Jupiter apérus il n'y a parfois qu'un
petit pas vous ne pouvez pas madame la
Première ministre gouverner non
seulement saint mais contre le peuple et
ses représentants c'est dangereux pour
le pays c'est dangereux pour sa cohésion
c'est dangereux pour notre démocratie
plutôt que de céder à la brutalité
constitutionnelle renoncer à votre
projet faites le choix du respect faites
le choix de l'apaisement merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne alors vous appelez
au dialogue monsieur le Président
reconnaissez qu'avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft nous avons
régulièrement dialoguer concerté avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales avec les représentants des
groupes parlementaires et je le dis
comme je l'ai déjà fait comme le
président de la République l'a également
affirmé la porte du gouvernement celle
du ministre du Travail reste
naturellement ouverte pour recevoir
l'Inter syndicale si elle le souhaite
monsieur le Président Chassagne vous
appelez également au respect du
Parlement mais assumer que c'est vous
qui depuis des semaines opposé la
légitimité de la rue à celle du
Parlement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
assumer qu'avec vos partenaires de la
nups vous vouliez empêcher la discussion
et le vote assumez que vous avez fait le
choix de l'obstruction alors même qu'il
y a déjà eu plus de temps de débat sur
cette réforme des retraites que sur les
deux précédentes et monsieur le
Président Charles pour finir parlons
concrètement et assumer votez contre
cette réforme c'est dire à toutes les
infirmières libérales à toutes les
femmes qui exercent des professions
libérales qu'elles devront renoncer à
une majoration de 10% de leur pension
assumer que voter contre cette réforme
c'est dire à 1,8 millions de retraités
que leur potion n'augmentera pas cet été
en moyenne de 600 euros par an assumez
que voter contre cette réforme c'est
dire à des Françaises et à des Français
qui ont commencé à travailler avant 16
ans qu'ils devront travailler 45 ans
alors que nous leur proposons de partir
plus plutôt travaillant moins longtemps
assumez que voter contre cette réforme
c'est dire au chauffeur de bus du
Puy-de-Dôme qu'il devra travailler
davantage que le chauffeur de bus de
Paris monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président chaseigne Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés il y a des moments
démocratiques où il faut assumer tout
simplement assumer
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
pompe pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente de ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
Véran monsieur le ministre beaucoup de
praticiens arrivent aujourd'hui à l'âge
de la retraite et les nouvelles
générations actuelles ne sont pas encore
assez nombreuses pour compenser ses
départs pour les patients cela se
traduit par des difficultés croissantes
à trouver un médecin généraliste
traitant et entraîne une multiplication
des déserts médicaux dans certaines
régions une première solution notamment
été apportée avec la disparition du
numerus clausus mais ces nouvelles
générations de médecins n'arriveront que
dans 8 ans au mieux
quelques pistes peuvent être envisagées
nos jeunes collègues plébiscitent les
maisons de santé et ce système amplement
poussé par l'État permet d'assurer une
continuité dans le parcours de santé par
exemple dans ma circonscription du
Boulonnais 23 médecins se sont regroupés
pour proposer 40 consultations libres
par semaine nous pourrions soutenir
également la création de cabinet
secondaire ou de cabinet itinérants se
déplaçant chaque jour dans un secteur
diversifié
désertifié différents médecins
généralistes il me semble normal pour ma
part d'intégrer le groupe d'études qui
vient d'être créé sur les déserts
médicaux et l'accès aux soins je délègue
développerai plus précisément ces idées
au sein de ce groupe d'études monsieur
le ministre je vous saurais fort
reconnaissant de bien vouloir nous faire
connaître pour lutter contre ces déserts
médicaux quelle première piste vous-même
vous envisagez je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Pierre pon pour qu'il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté je le précise ici François
Braun est en déplacement sur le
territoire sa ministre délégué également
c'est pourquoi je répondrai aux
questions qui ont lieu qui ont trait à
la santé monsieur le député Jean-Pierre
pon vous interrogez le gouvernement sur
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux et
vous avez raison de poser cette question
en quête d'opinion après enquête
d'opinion sondage après sondage le sujet
qui est systématiquement sur le podium
des préoccupations de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens c'est l'accès aux soins et
notamment l'accès aux médecins vous le
savez monsieur le député nous manquons
de médecins sur le sol français nous
manquons de médecin parce que pendant
près de 50 ans l'État a empêché des
jeunes Français d'apprendre la médecine
en France et nous avons supprimé l'outil
qui empêchait cette formation le numerus
clausus en 2018 mais comme vous le savez
quand vous même médecin il faut 10 ans
pour former un médecin et donc les
fruits de cette juste est urgente
décision ne sont pas à récolter tout de
suite dans l'intervalle comment
pour nous d'abord nous agissons sur
l'organisation des soignants dans les
territoires avec un maître mot épargné
du temps médical réduire les tâches
administratives ce sont ces centaines
ces milliers d'assistants médicaux qui
viennent partout les médecins sont
regroupés permettent d'épargner du temps
médical c'est cette délégation de tâches
et délégation d'actes à des soignants
paramédicaux du manformer qui offre des
soins de qualité y compris demain en
accès direct grâce à un récent vote de
l'Assemblée nationale qui permet
d'éviter d'aller chez le médecin quand
on peut aller consulter un autre
professionnel c'est aussi l'organisation
et le maillage en fameuse CPTs sur tout
le territoire national je crois aussi à
la télémédecine nous sommes passés à la
faveur si je puis dire du covid de
quelques dix mille actes après d'un
million d'actes de télémédecine par
semaine ça ne résout pas tout mais cela
peut aider enfin un mot de la méthode
celle de la concertation celle de
l'innovation dans les territoires à
travers les conseils nationaux de la
refondation des centaines d'entre eux se
tiennent partout sur le territoire on en
parle peut-être moins à Paris mais je
peux vous garantir que la Wilson
on identifie des solutions efficaces et
enfin l'objectif 700 000 malades en
affection longue durée auront bientôt un
médecin traitant merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur
François Ruffin pour le groupe la France
insoumise
mesdames messieurs du gouvernement et
derrière vous monsieur le Président vous
êtes le coyote de Tex Avery vous savez
il court il court il a franchi la
falaise et sous lui c'est le vide il a
découvre il découvre ce vide et soudain
il chute je vous écoute je vous regarde
et c'est ce vide qui me frappe ce vide
en vous ce vide sous vous pour le dire
autrement avec un propos plus intello
Antonio est comme si écrivait je cite la
classe dominante a perdu le consentement
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'est plus
dirigeante mais uniquement dominante et
seulement détentrice d'une pure force de
coercition
voilà le moment que nous vivons que se
passe-t-il vous le gouvernement vous le
Président vous les dominants vous ne
dirigez plus vous ne cherchez même plus
à diriger c'est-à-dire à entraîner le
peuple à obtenir son consentement non
désormais vous faites ça convaincre de
la justesse de la justice de votre
projet vous avez à peine essayé quelques
arguments brouillon des chiffres bidons
et très vite vous avez baissé pavillon
vous l'avez acté deux Français sur 3 ils
sont opposés et alors tous les syndicats
sont unis contre vous et alors une deux
trois quatre manifestations 1 2 3
millions de personnes et alors les
raffineries sont bloquées les dalchers
pas ramassés et alors pour reculer
dites-vous il vous faudrait des morts
le coyote de Tex Avery est comique lui
vous êtes vous tragique vous êtes des
dangers ou des dangers pour les Français
car que faites-vous vous punissez les
travailleurs qui ont tenu le pays de
bout vous instillez dans le cœur des
dégoûts vous écrasez une démocratie que
vous devriez soigner vous abîmer un pays
qui nous faut réparer
alors chers collègues de droits du
centre des marcheurs même de partout
j'en appelle à votre responsabilité oui
oui pourquoi faire le grand saut avec
Macron boulet ou pied jeudi voté non
pour un camp non pour un clan mais en
votre âme est conscience votez au mieux
pour la France
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail et de l'insertion et
du plein emploi
merci madame la Présidente
je crains un monsieur le député avec ma
réponse soit brève puisque vous n'avez
pas posé de questions
vous n'avez pas posé de questions vous
n'avez pas pu vous empêcher de succomber
finalement vos péchés l'outrans une
forme d'insultes déguisé et la volonté
de vouloir prendre une hauteur que vous
n'atteindrez jamais vous avez terminé
sur un mot responsabilité la
responsabilité c'est celle de cette
majorité la responsabilité c'est de
porter une réforme qui permet
d'équilibrer le système qui permettent
de créer de nouveaux droits qui
permettent de regarder nos enfants et
nos petits-enfants dans les yeux en leur
disant que nous avons préservé un
système de solidarité dont ils vont
pouvoir bénéficier la responsabilité
c'est de faire en sorte d'élargir
d'intégrer d'améliorer le texte de
l'améliorer ici si vous ne nous aviez
pas empêché d'en discuter de l'améliorer
au Sénat avec des mesures favorables
Omer de famille avec des mesures
favorables celles et ceux qui
travaillent avec des mesures de lutte
contre la fraude avec une amélioration
de celles et ceux qui ont les carrière
les plus longues la responsabilité c'est
de faire vous vous contentez de
contester et parfois même vous vous
essayez à déclamer ça ne suffit pas pour
agir ça ne suffit pas pour être efficace
ça ne suffit pas pour être responsable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur Jean-Jacques
Gauthier pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente ma question à
laquelle j'associe Stéphane Viry
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
santé et de la prévention et concerne la
situation alarmante de l'hôpital public
avec l'entrée en vigueur de la loi riste
dans quelques jours
l'encadrement des rémunérations des
médecins intérimaires est une intention
louable et même souhaitable mais pas
dans les conditions actuelles qui vont
avoir des conséquences terribles sur
l'organisation de l'offre de soins dans
la région Grand Est 90% des
établissements sont touchés dans les
Vosges la continuité de service est
assurée par le seul recours à l'intérim
dans de nombreuses spécialités l'offre
de soins est en grand danger avec des
fermetures de services à risque vital
fermeture de la maternité d'Épinal avec
plus de 1200 accouchements par an ou
fermeture des urgences de Vittel qui
doivent pourtant fonctionner 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24
81% de la population
par le service des urgences de Vittel 44
000 habitants 150 communes rurales se
trouveraient à plus de 30 minutes et le
site de vitesse dans son ensemble par
effet domino serait menacé c'est
inacceptable en terme de santé publique
et en terme d'économie et cela
confirmerait encore les inégalités
d'accès aux soins d'urgence entre ruraux
et urbains alors Monsieur le Ministre
prendrez-vous la responsabilité d'acter
une telle décision
je vous remercie la parole
éthique et porte-parole du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Gauthier vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur effectivement une
mesure de régulation qui va permettre de
mettre un coup important je l'espère
fatal aux dérives d'une pratique de
l'intérim médical tout intérim n'est pas
jeter à la poubelle bien sûr il y en a
qui peut être nécessaire lorsqu'il
s'agit de remplacer un congé maladie ou
maternité par exemple mais lorsque
l'intérim devient la norme lorsque des
médecins exigent 1500 2000 2500 euros
pour 24 heures ça met en péril la
continuité des soins ça met en péril la
sécurité financière de l'établissement
et ça crée une spirale inflationniste
c'est pourquoi les parlementaires
avaient décidé de mettre en place une
régulation avec un plafonnement qui
n'est pas déraisonnable puisqu'il est de
1162 euros pour 24 heures de travail
renouvelable évidemment dans la semaine
et dans le mois
monsieur le député Gauthier les
habitants de votre territoire les
soignants de votre territoire soient
savent pouvoir compter sur votre
détermination à préserver les structures
de soins dans la région de Vittel vous
citez notamment les urgences et vous
avez associé le député viril que
j'associe bien volontiers à ma réponse
sachez désormais que les habitants de
votre territoire et les soignants de
votre territoire pourront aussi compter
sur la détermination du gouvernement et
donc de l'État pour faire en sorte que
les structures de soins auxquels vous
faites allusion notamment les structures
de soins en lien avec l'hôpital de
Vittel puisse être organisés de matières
à assurer dans la durée la continuité et
la sécurité des soins nous laisserons
pas ces structures fermées ni péricliter
ni même s'abîmer ne serait-ce que et
vous l'avez dit parce que vous êtes dans
un territoire qui est soumis à une forte
saisonnalité avec une population qui
grandit pendant la période estivale
parce que c'est une région agréable donc
compter sur notre détermination et nous
continuerons de travailler avec vous je
parle au nom évidemment du ministre
François Brown à qui je m'en suis
entretenu avant de vous répondre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Gauthier c'est vrai qu'après
les merci du covid et les promesses du
Ségur on ne peut se contenter de
constater la situation de dire on attend
15 jours et on regarde comment ça se
passe on ne peut pas jouer à pile ou
face avec la santé de nos concitoyens et
le moral des personnels hospitaliers le
premier devoir de l'État et de protéger
les Français notamment en matière de
santé
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne bruniera
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
la laïcité est un des fondements de
notre école républicaine depuis Jules
Ferry elle se doit de protéger nos
élèves qui sont des esprits en formation
de toute forme de prosélytisme mais
cette laïcité à laquelle nous apportons
tant de prix piliers de notre contrat
social et garantie de notre vivre
ensemble et contestée par une frange
minoritaire mais agissante plusieurs
études en témoignent ainsi que les
statistiques de votre ministère le
nombre d'atteintes à la laïcité a ainsi
atteint un pic de 720 en octobre dernier
une enquête Ifop a montré que plus d'un
enseignant sur deux a été confronté à
une atteinte à la laïcité depuis la
rentrée de 2021 et une enquête du SNPDEN
confirme cette tendance en soulignant
une part importante de non signalement
face à ce phénomène vous avez annoncé en
novembre dernier un plan laïcité avec
plusieurs axes tout d'abord des
sanctions systématiques et graduées pour
les élèves ayant un comportement portant
atteinte à la laïcité si ce comportement
bien sûr persiste a pris une phase de
dialogue ensuite c'est important le
renforcement de la protection et du
soutien aux personnel l'appui au chef
d'établissement le renforcement de la
formation de tous les personnels et en
premier lieu des chefs d'établissement
ce travail est un travail de longue
haleine il faut du temps pour que les
outils mis en place produisent leurs
effets pour que les méthodes soient
intégrées il faut aussi faire confiance
aux enseignants qui sont en première
ligne et être à leur écoute ainsi
l'enquête du s.n.pden au-delà de ses
biens méthodologiques peut néanmoins
être l'occasion d'un travail avec les
sonder pour aller plus loin et pour
lever leur propre frein au signalement
il est important de suivre la situation
de près il est important d'en parler
surtout parce qu'en parler c'est ancré
ce sujet des atteintes à la laïcité dans
l'esprit de chacun cette vigilance dans
l'esprit de tous et que les sache qu'ils
sont soutenus dans cette lutte si
délicate je sais Monsieur le Ministre
votre détermination sur ce point aussi
pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
perspectives sur lesquelles travaillent
votre ministère en termes de lutte
contre les atteintes à la laïcité dans
nos établissements scolaires je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Papen
DIY ministre de l'éducation nationale
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Anne brunira vous l'avez dit la question
de la laïcité à l'école et fondamentale
c'est la condition sinequanone de la
formation d'esprit libre et de
l'émancipation de nos élèves face à
l'augmentation des atteintes à la
laïcité à l'automne dernier nous avons
agi pour ne pas laisser de place à ceux
qui tentent de fragiliser les fondements
de la République et qui ne veulent ni de
bien à nos élèves ni à l'école ni à la
République c'est pour cela que j'ai pris
une série de mesures d'abord encourager
personnel éducatif à signalé tout
atteinte nous avons renforcé les équipes
valeurs de la République 600 personnes
aujourd'hui leur donner les outils la
formation et la protection nécessaire
pour ce faire et enfin rendre public
mensuellement les chiffres d'atteinte à
la laïcité j'ai été très clair sur les
instructions qui ont été passées au
recteur et au chef d'établissement
d'abord vous l'avez dit le dialogue avec
les élèves et avec leur famille puisque
l'élève l'école c'est d'abord le lieu de
la pédagogie ensuite effectivement quand
le dialogue ne porte pas ses fruits il y
a conseil de discipline et sanction
depuis la rentrée les chiffres
d'atteinte à la laïcité ont baissé de
manière significative mais je n'en tire
aucune conclusion hâtive il nous faut
persévérer justement une des enquêtes
que vous évoquez reflète la vie de
certains chefs d'établissements je les
encourage à ne rien cacher et les
formons pour cela il faut absolument ne
pas mettre la poussière sur le sous le
tapis offrir toutes les garanties pour
que les signalements puissent s'exercer
le plus sereinement le combat contre les
atteintes à la laïcité est un travail de
conviction d'opiniâtreté et de fermeté
sur les principes et sur les actes je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Guy Bricout
pour le groupe liotte merci Madame et
présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Lescure ministre délégal
industrie le Cambrésis est en état de
choc deux des plus gros employeurs
agroalimentaires de ma circonscription
Nestlé et Tereos ont annoncé la
fermeture de leur usine entraînant des
suppressions de postes massives de
nombreuses manifestations de soutien ont
déjà été organisées j'ai vu des salariés
pleurer je les plains ils ne sont pour
rien Nestlé a récemment rénové l'usine
Buitoni a déclaré relancé la chaîne de
pizza cuite ça a été fait pendant 15
jours mais elle est à nouveau à l'arrêt
depuis le 5 mars c'est aujourd'hui 150
salariés leurs familles qui sont
menacées il n'est pas concevable qu'un
groupe comme Nestlé ne puisse envisager
une solution pérenne pour la sauvegarde
d'une activité sur le site des solutions
existent certainement une Nestlé se doit
de les mettre en œuvre dans la même
semaine toujours dans ma CIR description
c'est un autre employeur très important
de l'industrie agroalimentaire Tereos
deuxième sucrier mondiale qui annonce
brusquement aux salariés de la sucrerie
décodeur l'arrêt de l'activité au total
ce sont 400 emplois direct ou indirects
qui demain vont disparaître sur ce seul
site les salariés qui ont consacré une
grande partie de leur vie pour leur
employeur qui ont donné le meilleur de
même ne mérite pas se mépris de la part
d'entreprise qui dégage par ailleurs de
gros bénéfices sur un territoire comme
le mien déjà très marqué par le chômage
25%. c'est donc plus de 1000 emplois qui
en une semaine risque d'être supprimés
je parle aussi des emplois collatéraux
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
vous être déplacé hier dans mes
circonscriptions et de discuter avec
toutes les parties concernées vous avez
su faire preuve d'autorité je vous en
remercie ma question est simple les
salariés de l'usine Nestlé de Caudry et
de la sucrerie terrestre décodeur
pourront-ils compter sur une action du
gouvernement qui me permettra de
sauvegarder les nombreux emplois
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député Guy
Bricout merci à vous merci et merci
surtout de votre engagement auprès des
salariés vous l'en avez témoigné hier
avec Madame le parmentier le coq pardon
qui était à vos côtés et aussi
l'ensemble des élus municipaux
départementaux et régionaux y compris le
président du département et du président
de la Région face à deux décisions vous
l'avez dit qui ont sonné comme deux
coups de tonnerre dans un territoire qui
décidément n'en n'avait pas besoin vous
l'avez dit j'ai rencontré les directions
des deux entreprises deux situations
extrêmement différentes et je dois vous
dire aujourd'hui que je n'ai été
satisfait des réponses ni de l'une ni de
l'autre concernant Nestlé vous l'avez
dit je ne souhaite pas il est impensable
que les salariés soient les victimes
collatérales d'un drame sanitaire dont
l'innocent en aucun cas responsable il
est indispensable que Nestlé organise de
la production sur ce site qu'on produise
des pizzas qu'on produise d'autres
choses je leur ai donné deux semaines
pour me faire une proposition et je les
attends au pied ferme pour m'assurer que
ce sera le cas en ce qui concerne
l'entreprise Tereos la situation est
différente c'est une entreprise qui a
décidé de fermer un site ça arrive
malheureusement mais je ne comprends pas
et je n'accepte pas les raisons qui
m'ont été données une entreprise qui
perdait de l'argent il y a quelques
années qui ont gagné aujourd'hui une
entreprise qui était endettée qui se
désendette une entreprise qui est sur un
marché qui est aujourd'hui porteur dont
le prix est en hausse je ne me satisfais
pas des explications qui m'ont été
données ces trois jours que je leur ai
donné le préfet les recevra jeudi avec
les élus vous y êtes combien pour
entendre leurs explications et enfin
c'est important dans un territoire vous
l'avez dit difficile j'ai annoncé hier
un dispositif rebond industriel
particulier qui sera doté de 3 millions
d'euros et qui permettra d'accompagner
les industriels qui souhaitent
développer votre territoire vous en
connaissez de manière à sortir ce
territoire malheureux de leur dire dans
lequel ces deux décisions risquent de le
mettre merci monsieur le député
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur
jérémyordano pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre vous avez
été nommé par le chef de l'État nous
avons été élu par le peuple français
vous le savez Emmanuel Macron est là
grâce au barrage contre l'extrême droite
il n'a pas de majorité sur son programme
vous avez refusé en contradiction avec
l'esprit et la lettre de la Constitution
d'engager la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement devant la représentation
nationale pour maltraiter la
Constitution
vous avez mis la réforme des retraites
dans le projet de loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour ne pas griller un 49-3 c'est
absurde l'usage du 47,1 permet le temps
contraint et la législation par
ordonnance législation dérogatoire
justifiée par l'urgence ça n'a aucun
sens pour une réforme des retraites vous
maltraités la Constitution madame la
Première ministre
vous n'écoutez pas les syndicats vous
brusquez la procédure législative
vous faites fi des millions de
Françaises et de Français qui défilent
pacifiquement dans les rues
et vous avez l'autre cuit danse de
laisser entendre que vous pourriez faire
usage de la procédure de législation
forcée
à l'heure où le président de la
République veut réformer les
institutions comment pouvez-vous ignorer
la demande de démocratie de débat de
délibération dans notre pays alors ou
nombre de nos concitoyens se détournent
des urnes ou le rassemblement national
parti autoritaire et il libéral
s'approche dangereusement du pouvoir
entendait les alertes entendez les
alertes contre le passage en force ne
jetez plus de l'huile sur le feu
si nous voulons éviter le désordre d'un
côté et la réaction autoritaire de
l'autre
les tensions doivent se résoudre dans un
cadre institutionnel
respectueux de la délibération et de la
séparation des pouvoirs
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député ayant
permettez-moi d'abord monsieur le député
de vous rappeler puisque visiblement
vous l'avez oublié qu'après avoir été
nommé première ministre Madame Elisabeth
borne ici présente c'est présenté devant
les électeurs c'est présenté devant les
électeurs lors des élections
législatives et dans son programme que
dans le programme de tous les députés de
la majorité il y avait la réforme des
retraites et cette engagement de mener
la réforme des retraites a été pris par
le Président de la République comme il a
été pris par l'ensemble des députés de
la majorité présidentielle vous nous
dites monsieur le député il n'y a pas de
débat des mois de concertation que nous
avons mené avec la première ministre les
partenaires sociaux pour améliorer pour
enrichir le texte des centaines d'heures
de débats ici même l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat auront débattu au total
presque 180 heures du projet de réforme
des retraites d'autres assemblées
d'autres assemblée aurait pu aller au
bout du texte si vous n'aviez pas fait
le choix de l'obstruction le Sénat est
allé au bout du texte vous nous dites
vous utilisez des procédures vous
j'imagine que vous faites référence aux
procédures constitutionnelles donc
démocratique que nous avons utilisé au
Sénat nous avons nous avons mis en œuvre
des articles de la Constitution les
mêmes qui avaient été mis en œuvre au
moment de la réforme de 2003 au moment
de la réforme de 2013 sur la loi de
sécurisation de l'emploi tout ce qui a
été fait dans le cadre de ce débat
s'inscrit dans un cadre constitutionnel
monsieur le député vous n'écoutez pas la
réponse que je vous fais mais sachez une
chose c'est que dans cette majorité
jamais nous opposerons la légitimité du
Parlement à la légitimité de la rue et
quand vous nous dites écoutez les
messages pour éviter le désordre bien
souvent nous avons le sentiment que
c'est vous qui appelez au désordre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie-Agnès
poussiez vinceback pour le groupe
horizon madame le présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires c'est aujourd'hui une
journée toute particulière pour les
communes littorales puisque c'est en
effet aujourd'hui que le comité national
du trait de côte est installé par Madame
la Ministre Bérengère Couillard
à Fécamp ville qui certains le savent
est très cher à mon coeur et dont je
suis toujours une élue municipale un
éboulement de Falaise très
impressionnant a eu lieu ces derniers
jours en portant notre calvaire et ce
qui devait selon le céréma tomber à la
mer au cours du siècle à venir mes chers
collègues ces événements autrefois
exceptionnels deviennent aujourd'hui
récurrents au pays du haut de falaises
comme ailleurs faut-il sensibiliser plus
notre population sans doute mais nous le
faisons déjà au travers notamment des
actions engagées par les différents
syndicats mixtes littoraux auprès de nos
habitants au delà de ces informations et
de cette sensibilité il est urgent
d'armer au plus vite les communes face
aux risques et de trouver des
financements pour les accompagner
c'est le rôle de ce comité national du
trait de côte les mers ont besoin d'une
générique ils ont besoin d'être aidés au
regard des contraintes complémentaires
dès lors que nos territoires entrent
dans la liste des communes sujettes à
l'érosion sujettes aux submersion marine
également en effet nous devons avoir une
approche très différente de celle que
nous avons pu avoir depuis toujours en
matière d'urbanisme en terme de
politique d'aménagement comme pour les
marnières il sera nécessaire d'aller au
bout de la construction d'un dispositif
qui puisse accompagner financièrement
les différents concernés avec un fond
d'érosion côtière par exemple chez moi
comme partout comme dans le Pays des
Hautes Falaises concrètement ce sont
certaines routes qui seront coupées de
nouveaux ouvrages qui devront être
financés des habitants et des quartiers
restructurés je forme le vœu que ce
nouveau comité associe la question du
recul mais aussi celui de la submersion
marine trop souvent traitée dans une
logique de silo par des acteurs et des
services de l'État parfois différents
j'espère que vous pourrez nous exposer
aujourd'hui votre ambition je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
poussier windsback je vous remercie déjà
pour votre question qui me donne
l'occasion de mettre en avant le
lancement ce jour du Comité national du
trait de côte et également vous assurer
évidemment de ma pleine mobilisation sur
au sein du gouvernement sur un sujet
éminemment stratégique pour nos
littéraux je me suis rendu à Camier
ainsi qu'à Soulac récemment et chaque
territoire comme Fécamp est unique mais
le constat est le même il est urgent
d'anticiper avec le réchauffement
climatique le niveau des mers et des
Océans vamentés 20% des littoraux sont
concernés en cas de réchauffement des
températures supérieures à 2 degrés
l'eau pourrait monter d'un mètre d'ici
2100 d'après une étude du serréma
jusqu'à 50 000 logements pour être
concernés à horizon 2100 nous n'avons
pas attendu pour agir vous l'avez
mentionné de nouvelles mesures ont été
prises dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résilience dés sur la base du
volontariat les communes peuvent
s'identifier via un décret pour
travailler sur ce sujet 126 communes
sont déjà portées volontaires et
d'autres inscriptions sont à venir
j'espère d'ailleurs que fécan en fera
partie nous investissons en 2023 20
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
collectivités aux financement de
l'ingénierie des cartographies et
également des premières opérations les
moyens déployés permettent donc de
répondre aux besoins présents mais nous
n'avons nous avons et nous devons aussi
construire une capacité pérenne de
financement des adaptations nécessaires
de nos littoraux nous devons passer
d'une politique de gestion des risques à
une politique d'aménagement du
territoire ce jour marque donc le
lancement officiel d'une concertation
dans le cadre du commissaire du Comité
national du Traite côte qui est une
commission du Conseil national maire et
littoral nos réflexions doivent répondre
à trois questions qu'allons-nous
financer quels sont les besoins de
financement et quels sont les leviers de
financement l'objectif du gouvernement
est clair un an de concertation pour
inscrire une stratégie de financement
dans le projet de loi de finances 2021
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à monsieur Adrien Clouet pour
la France insoumise
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement depuis plusieurs semaines
des révélations se succèdent on voyait
la silhouette des députés macronistes on
découvre qu'elle cache l'ombre
d'actionnaires privés qui font la loi
selon des intérêts particuliers
six mois dans ce pays que nous plaidons
en faveur d'un blocage des prix de
l'essence et d'une taxation de super
profit six mois que vous tournez autour
du pot et que découvre-t-on que Madame
la Ministre firme un Baudot est accélère
de Total énergie ainsi que Monsieur le
Ministre Ndiaye ainsi que les députés
ponts le député Fiévé la député Melchior
la députée Cristol et j'arrête là deux
minutes ne suffirait pas tous
actionnaires de Total tu m'étonnes qui
votes contre taxer les super profits et
c'est le cas pour absolument tous les
grands monopoles qui sont représentés
dans cette hémicycle je pense aux député
Jean-René Cazeneuve 350 000 euros
d'actions chez Bouygues chez Bouygues
opérateur par ailleurs que nous sommes
obligés d'utiliser avec nos téléphones à
l'Assemblée je suis ravi qu'à chaque SMS
je vous profite personnellement alors
bien sûr nous nous méfions à l'heure de
débattre du régime de retraite et de
votre réforme nous vous demandons qui
ici a des intérêts particuliers et
personnels qui ici
ah des investissements dans des plans
d’épargne retraite qui investit dans des
fonds de pension à part madame la
ministre ou des hack à STERA 2 millions
d'actions dans les assurances et les
régimes bancaires ainsi que le crédit la
seule gagnante de la réforme c'est elle
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Clouet vous parlez de Total mais c'est
vous qui allez finir par trouver du
pétrole à force de toucher le fond comme
vous le faites encore aujourd'hui
vous parlez d'actionnaires vous parlez
d'actionnaires vous restez le premier
actionnaire de la démagogie en France et
vous partagez les dividendes avec
l'autre extrême de l'hémicycle
cette démagogie
cette démagogie elle est non seulement
scandaleuse mais elle est dangereuse
elle est dangereuse parce qu'en
proférance ce type d'attaque finalement
vous en venez à délégitimer des règles
qui ont été mises en place de
transparence précisément pour prévenir
les conflits d'intérêts précisément pour
que tout soit mis sur la table c'est ses
règles là auxquelles vous vous attaquez
avec ce type de propos elle est
dangereuse parce que vous mentez aux
Français cette majorité ce gouvernement
n'a pas eu la main qui tremble pour
taxer les super profits et notamment
ceux de Total dans le dernier PLF vous
vous y êtes opposé vous vous y êtes
opposé
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Clouet
merci madame la Présidente alors
évidemment on attend des guerres de
réponse mais je suis surpris qu'il y ait
des aveux c'est encore mieux je retiens
une chose de nos échanges extrêmement
prompte à venir invectiver les éboueurs
qui laissent traîner de poubelles en bas
de la rue dans une lutte pour leur droit
elle existence mais faire le ménage dans
vos comptes bancaires c'est au-dessus de
vos forces
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente
vous avez passé l'intégralité des débats
plusieurs centaines d'heures de débats à
parler taxation des super profits à
parler de Total
ce qui est aussi dangereux pour notre
système de retraite puisque quand vous
dites que vous voulez payer les pensions
des Français avec les super profits
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les années où il y
a pas de super profit on baisse les
pensions c'est ça le modèle que vous
portez la réalité c'est que vous n'avez
qu'une seule cible vous n'avez qu'une
seule cible c'est la France qui
travaille et qui se lève le matin pour
aller travailler vous avez proposé
d'augmenter la CSG à partir de 1600
euros de revenus ça touchait pas total
ça touchait les Français qui travaillent
vous allez proposer taxer les heures
supplémentaires ça ne touchait pas total
ça touchait un salarié sur deux vous
avez proposé taxer l'intéressement et la
participation ça ne touchait pas total
ça touchait 5 millions de salariés la
réalité c'est que la France n'est pas un
paradis fiscal mais que vous voulez en
faire un enfer pour tous les Français
qui travaille et vous ne nous laisseront
pas le faire
[Applaudissements]
il y a qu'une seule réponse monsieur
Clouet pas de
c'est notre règlement
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Mazar
pour le comprenez ça ensemble
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Marc
fenault ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire
il y a des jours la 59e édition du Salon
de l'Agriculture baisser le rideau et
les Français ont répondu présent avec un
engouement particulièrement important
monsieur le ministre vous avez été au
contact de la ferme France comme
d'ailleurs bon nombre d'entre nous
députés heureux de voir les acteurs de
nos territoires convergés vers la
capitale pour donner à voir ce qu'ils
font de mieux j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour vous remercier de l'attention
particulière que vous avez accordé aux
acteurs agricoles de mon département
si notre agriculture au cours de ce
salon et comme chaque année séparé de
ses plus beaux habits cela n'occulte en
rien les difficultés et les doutes que
celles-ci rencontre au quotidien ces
inquiétudes vous le savez c'est
notamment la question climatique avec
des adaptations qui sont d'ores et déjà
en cours mais qui doivent encore
s'accélérer
la question de la déprise en zone
d'élevage avec une décapitalisation du
cheptel particulièrement qui est
atteinte
la question de la prédation et des
nuisible qui s'attaque au moyen de
production aux animaux eux-mêmes la
question de l'équilibre économique à de
l'augmentation des coûts de production
enfin la question normative avec parfois
une sur réglementation préjudiciable à
la compétitivité de nos filières au
regard de ces nombreuses inquiétudes on
peut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une désaffection pour le beau métier
d'agricultrice et d'agriculteurs surtout
si on y rajoute l'engagement que ce
métier suscite en termes de travail et
les sacrifices auxquels il faut
consentir
à l'heure des choix l'agriculture
française a besoin de Cape clair
monsieur le ministre vous avez pu lors
du salon vous exprimer à plusieurs
reprises sur votre vision de notre
aviculture et de notre souveraineté
alimentaire pouvez-vous nous en redire
ici les grandes lignes pouvez-vous nous
dire aussi quelles seront les grandes
lignes de ce projet de loi que nous
examinerons bientôt et qui doit redonner
de l'attractivité à ce secteur éviter le
pire car monsieur le ministre comme le
disait la véroné Raymond Lacombe
président son temps de la FNSEA il n'y a
pas de pays sans paysage
la parole est à Monsieur Marc phénom
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés merci monsieur le
député Mazar de votre question qui
permet à la fois de faire un bilan du
salon et de donner des perspectives
premier bilan du salon c'est d'abord la
grande affluence qu'il y a eu qui a
permis à de nombreux Français à de
nombreux d'entre vous et d'entre nous de
voir et de rencontrer les agriculteurs
de rencontrer leurs difficultés mais de
rencontrer aussi ce que sont leurs
attentes et leurs innovations et leur
volonté d'avancer dans les grandes
transitions qui sont à l'œuvre
vous l'avez dit on a pu au cours de ce
salon évoquer la question de la
souveraineté fruits et légumes elle
avait l’annonce d'un plan de
souveraineté fruits et légumes on a pu
aussi avancer sur les questions de
modernisation de l'appareil dans la
ligne droite de ce qui a été fait dans
le plan France 2030 et France Roland
préalablement pour montrer à quel point
nous voulons accompagner l'agriculture
dans les grandes transformations qui
sont à l'oeuvre vous l'avez dit aussi on
a besoin de donner un cap à
l'agriculture si je devais donner un
seul cap c'est celui de la souveraineté
la souveraineté au fond c'est quoi la
souveraineté c'est de donner les moyens
de production les moyens de production
c'est quoi c'est l'accès aux foncier
c'est l'accès au capitaux c'est l'accès
à l'eau c'est l'accès aux moyens de
production globalement qui permettront
aux agriculteurs de faire face aux
grands défis qui sont les nôtres le
deuxième élément de la souveraineté
c'est de faire face aux dérèglement
climatique et au nouveau besoin
entièremental c'est de donner les moyens
par la recherche par l'innovation par
l'accompagnement à l'investissement à
nos agriculteurs de pouvoir se
transformer d'évoluer le le statu quo en
agriculture avec le dérèglement
climatique serait une grande peur une
grande crainte et un grand défi si nous
ne rêvions pas à le relever il me semble
qu'on a besoin de travailler sur ce
sujet là le troisième sujet c'est le
sujet aussi de la rémunération c'est ce
que nous avons commencé à faire dans
egalim on envoie les premiers résultats
ne soyons pas tropérant de toi ou trop
auto satisfait mais on a vu les premiers
résultats des galets on a besoin de
rémunération parce que sans rémunération
il y aura pas d'attractivité des métiers
pas de capacité à investir pour les
agriculteurs voilà les éléments qu'on a
et puis vous avez dit pas d'agriculture
on dit souvent pas d'agriculture pas de
paysans pas de pays sans paysans c'était
la phrase de Raymond Lacombe nous avons
besoin nous avons besoin de renouer avec
une ambition agricole parce que la
France est forte quand son agriculture
est forte et c'est bien le cas le cap
que vous voulons tracer en termes de
souveraineté merci je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur Adrien catenas merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
dans le courrier de réponse qu'il a
adressé aux responsables syndicaux à
propos de la réforme des retraites le
président de la République reprend à son
compte le tissu de mensonge que le
gouvernement nous sert depuis le début
du débat parlementaire le premier des
mensonges c'est celui du déficit qui
justifierait cette réforme dans le
document faisant office d'études
d'impact publié par le gouvernement le
déficit est artificiellement gonflé en
tablant sur une diminution de la
contribution de l'État les déficits ils
sont affichés en euros courant sans
prendre en compte l'inflation et ne sont
pas rapportés au PIB comme le fait le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites car
rapporter au PIB le déficit est bien
moins impressionnant que l'affichage du
gouvernement les administrations de la
sécurité sociale resteraient largement
excédentaire notre système de protection
sociale est en bonne santé financière et
le déficit annoncé des retraites ne le
met en aucun cas en péril quel est donc
votre but c'est clairement de baisser
les dépenses publiques en général et non
pas de sauver le système de retraite
pour repasser sous le seuil des 3% de
déficit la fameuse est absurde exigence
de l'Union européenne à quel prix au
prix d'une réforme qui fera augmenter
deux fois plus l'âge de départ des
femmes que celui des hommes au prix
d'une réforme qui pénalisera les car
longue la hausse de la durée travaillée
serait 60% plus élevé pour celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
que pour l'ensemble de la population au
prix de mensonges sur la revalorisation
des minima de pension avec la réforme
40% des femmes retraitées et 15 % des
hommes retraités auront encore une
pension inférieure à 1200 euros les
mesures dites sociales concerneront bien
peu de monde quand le recul de l'âge de
départ lui concernera près de 400 000
personnes par an cette réforme fracture
le pays le débat parlementaire c'est la
démocratie mais la démocratie ne se
résume pas au débat parlementaire
entendez le cri de colère historique
venu de la rue et des piquets de grève
retirer cette réforme ou soumettez-la au
référendum
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le monsieur le député katnos
vous commencez votre vous avez débuté
votre question monsieur le député en
disant le déficit n'existe pas vous avez
dit le déficit de votre étude d'impact
c'était pas le déficit de l'étude
d'impact du gouvernement sur lequel nous
nous appuyons pour justifier de la
réforme c'est le déficit tel qu'il est
décrit tel qu'il est documenté dans
l'hypothèse centrale du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites auxquelles
participent l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux nous nous appuyons sur les
travaux du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites dont tout le monde c'est
l'indépendance comme tous les
gouvernements qui nous ont prêtés
précédés s'appuient sur ce document il y
a un déficit il y a un déficit et dès
2023 il approchera les 2 milliards
d'euros pour 2023 il sera de 12
milliards 5 en 2027 et il sera de 20
milliards d'euros en 2035 seul député si
nous ne faisons rien je l'ai dit avant
c'est 150 milliards de dettes en plus et
c'est un décrochage du niveau des
pensions par rapport au niveau des
salaires personne ne veut et je sais que
vous ne voulez pas non plus appauvrir
les retraités de notre pays pourtant si
nous ne faisons rien c'est ce qui va se
passer le texte tel que vous le
présentez n'est pas celui que nous
présentons au Parlement il a été
amélioré il a été enrichi les débats au
Sénat ont permis d'intégrer les
amendements que nous souhaitions
présentés ici dans le que l'obstruction
nous empêché pour mieux protéger les
carrières longues pour mieux revaloriser
les plus petites pensions pour mieux
valoriser les trimestres cotisés par les
femmes et notamment les ma famille dès
lors qu'elles ont une carrière complète
à 63 ans et qu'elles doivent continuer à
cotiser pendant quelques trimestres le
projet de loi tel qu'il vous sera
présenté si la commission mixte
paritaire en décide ainsi est un projet
qui était enrichi qui protège vous nous
dites monsieur le député que ce qui
compte à nos yeux c'est finalement la
comptabilité et les chiffres je vous
confirme que c'est une importance
capitale d'une importance capitale parce
que dans toutes les fonctions que j'ai
eu le privilège d'exercer comme mère
comme parlementaire comme membre du
gouvernement giacé une conviction c'est
que l'équipe des comptes c'est ce qui
permet d'agir l'équilibre des comptes
c'est ce que ce qui permet aussi à ceux
qui nous succèdent de pouvoir agir et
décider pour eux-mêmes donc oui cette
réforme à équilibré ce sera une réforme
de progrès mais nous voulons aussi que
ce soit une réforme équilibrée je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Marie-Christine Daloz pour
le groupe les républicains merci madame
la Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire le rapport public annuel de la
Cour des comptes pointe une situation
des finances publiques en 2023 parmi les
plus dégradés de la zone euro monsieur
le ministre nous ne pouvons plus
continuer dans cette voie la cour vous
exhorte à plus de responsabilités
budgétaire sans laquelle vous
précipiterez la France dans un gouffre
dont nous pourrons nous extraire notre
souveraineté est en péril la Commission
européenne juge ainsi élevée le risque
pour la soutenabilité de notre dette à
moyen terme elle dépassera 111% du
produit intérieur brut à la fin de
l'année
l'année 2023 devait sonner la fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte or les mesures
prises pour amortir le choc
inflationniste continueront de peser à
hauteur de 36 milliards d'euros sur la
dépense vous persistez dans cette
politique du carnet de chèque qui
consiste à déployer un catalogue de
mesure mal ciblés et donc trop coûteuse
à 58% du PIB la France allait dépenses
publiques les plus élevées de la zone
euro pour des services publics toujours
moins efficace
parallèlement les dépenses hors crise
continuent de s'envoler plus 3,5 en
volume pour 2022 hors inflation monsieur
le ministre nous décrochons sur tous les
fronts et vous regardez ailleurs leur
redressement de la trajectoire est
impératif est nécessitera une
détermination publique politique dont
vous n'avez jamais fait preuve depuis
qu'arrivera-t-il lorsque nous vous
retrouverons aux côtés de la Grèce ou de
l'Italie et de l'Italie dans le trio de
dettes des pays les plus endettés de la
zone euro
je vous remercie mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie et des finances
la député DALO j'aurais juste rappelé
que lorsque nous sommes arrivés en 2017
nous avons sorti la France la posture
pour déficit excessif rétablit les
comptes publics et que nous sommes
revenus sous les 3% de déficit public
s'agissant du rapport de la Cour des
comptes j'ai l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises nous partageons
d'autant plus le constat que je le fais
depuis le mois de juin et que nous avons
commencé à rétablir nos finances
publiques parce que c'est un impératif
qui est non négociable la première étape
c'est de sortir du quoiqu'il en coûte
nous avons discuter suffisamment
ensemble j'ai pu compter d'ailleurs sur
le soutien d'un certain nombre d'entre
vous pour mettre fin à une remise sur
l'intégralité du carburant pour tous les
consommateurs et la remplacer par une
indemnité carburant travailleur plus
ciblé
nous avons voulu cibler également les
aides aux entreprises sur celles qui en
ont le plus besoin c'est un débat entre
nous d'ailleurs je note que certains
d'entre vous voulaient que nous
préservions un bouclier pour toutes les
entreprises nous avons fait le choix des
aides ciblées pour sortir précisément du
quoi qu'il en coûte maintenant nous
avons un objectif nous avons un
calendrier et nous avons une méthode
l'objectif vous l'avez rappelé c'est de
passer de près de 58% de dépenses
publiques par rapport à notre richesse
nationale à 54% c'est le cap qui nous a
été fixé pour revenir sous les 3% de
déficit public en 2027 la méthode
cessait de la revue des dépenses
publiques nous allons voir chacune des
dépenses publiques de l'État des
collectivités locales des associations
pour voir sous l'autorité la première
ministre ou les économies peuvent être
faites et là aussi je compte sur votre
soutien votre vigilance et vos
propositions sur ce sujet enfin sur le
calendrier il est très précis je
recevrai le 30 mars prochain le premier
président de sur des comptes pierre
boscovici pour travailler avec lui nous
présenterons le programme de stabilité
de 12 avril nous aurons sous l'autorité
la première ministre un séminaire
gouvernemental pour réduire les dépenses
publiques de l'État et nous aurons des
Assises des finances publiques fin juin
pour préparer le projet de loi finance
2024 qui doit marquer des milliards
d'euros de réduction de merci beaucoup
madame Dalloz oui merci à un enseignant
à un élève dirait peu mieux faire nous
vous avons proposé un plan de sobriété
bureaucratique lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finance prenez ce
challenge là et allons vers une défense
plus efficace merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Roger
judo pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre de l'éducation nationale
parlons parcoursup et baccalauréat la
campagne 2023 parcoursup peut l'ancien
janvier s'achève les élèves de terminale
subissent les épreuves de spécialité de
la semaine prochaine leur note seront
capitales pour leur orientation dans le
supérieur les professeurs vous ont
pourtant alerté sur le fait que des
épreuves anticipées en mars n'ont pas de
valeur et donc gravement l'année
scolaire les programmes de spécialité
très exigeants ne peuvent être
valablement enseignées en un semestre
quand ils sont conçus pour une année
scolaire toute entière il s'ensuit que
la maîtrise des connaissances attendues
et partiel et peu assuré les notes
attribuées ne peuvent mesurer
correctement la maîtrise de ces
enseignements enfin après ces épreuves
les élèves se désintéressent le plus
souvent de ces matières désormais sans
enjeu pour eux l'année scolaire est
pratiquement terminée fin mars le
baccalauréat quant à lui réformé par
votre prédécesseur n'est plus qu'une
caricature
jadis premier diplôme de l'enseignement
supérieur et examen d'entrée à
l'université il n'est plus aujourd'hui
qu'un examen de fin d'année de lycée le
contrôle continu qui représente 40% de
la note finale en fait un examen de
moins en moins national et de plus en
plus local c'est taux de réussite
d'extravagants ces mentions bradées le
fait enfin qu'il ne servent à rien à
rien du tout dans la procédure
d'orientation et d'affectation dans le
supérieur en font au mieux un certificat
de présence l'ensemble parcoursup
nouveau bac est un système un système
parfaitement arbitraire et globalement
inefficace 21
000 formations dans parcoursup qui peut
s'y retrouver et en plus près de 120 000
élèves restent sur le carreau tous les
ans résultat 50% des bacheliers échouent
en première année de l'enseignement
supérieur bravo quand vous décidez-vous
monsieur le ministre a redonné sens des
valeurs académiques au baccalauréat
quand remplacerez-vous parcoursup par
une procédure plus juste quand
cessez-vous de vous intéresser davantage
à la vaccination ou à l'éducation
sexuelle des élèves plutôt qu'à
l'efficacité du système éducatif
[Musique]
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
judo pour la première fois en effet les
épreuves de spécialité du baccalauréat
se dérouleront entre le 20 et le 22 mars
ces épreuves contrairement à ce que vous
pensez sont adaptés le programme a été
resserré par l'Inspection générale au
mois de septembre et par conséquent les
épreuves pourront prendre en compte à
date ce qu'on effectivement étudié les
élèves deux motivation derrière cette ce
calendrier d'abord le fait de rendre au
mois de juin du temps d'enseignement
alors que celui-ci était amputé par
l'organisation de 6 à 10 épreuves et
donc on rend du temps scolaire pour les
élèves au mois de juin ce qui
caractérise et illustre la fameuse
reconquête du mois de juin elle permet
également une meilleure prise en compte
par les établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur des résultats des épreuves de
spécialité parce que ces épreuves de
spécialité seront prises en compte pour
la première fois par parcoursup et
redonneront ainsi toute sa valeur au
baccalauréat jusque à la fin du mois de
juin les élèves continueront à préparer
le grand oral ainsi que les preuves de
philosophie tout cela aura lieu au à la
mi-juin et puis ils pourront également
se préparer à une meilleure transition
vers l'enseignement supérieur cette
réforme engagée en 2018 vise à prendre
en compte la régularité du travail des
élèves c'est la première fois cette
année que les épreuves du nouveau bac
auront lieu dans des conditions normales
d'ailleurs à l'échelle du monde les
grands examens de fin de secondaire se
passe dans des conditions analogues le
baccalauréat était la dernière grande
épreuve à être organisée sous forme de
contrôle final alors Monsieur le Député
plutôt que de regarder dans le
rétroviseur d'un âge d'or prétendu
regardez concrètement la situation des
élèves je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est au président
brotherson pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente je suis un
collègue ma question s'adresse aux
ministres de la santé la Polynésie est
une collectivité d'outre-mer à statut
particulier qui a la compétence de la
santé mais bizarrement pas celle des
médicaments il en résulte une situation
du un peu bancale ou tout un ensemble de
plantes endémiques utilisées depuis la
fin le fond des âges pour soigner chez
nous se retrouvent interdit
d'utilisation
interdit d'utilisation parce qu'à défaut
d'être inscrite à la pharmacopée
nationale ce qui suppose donc un long
processus de reconnaissance via la NSM
elles sont tout simplement interdites
puisque non autorisé
ces plantes c'est savoir sont
aujourd'hui finalement menacés soit
d'instinction et
de finalement disparaître de la mémoire
collective faute de pouvoir les utiliser
correctement ou alors son sujet est à la
biopyrintherie de grands groupes qui
viennent étudie ces plantes dépose des
brevets et des possède finalement les
Polynésiens ne leur patrimoine naturelle
ma question ne vise pas à opposer le
gouvernement national à la collectivité
de Polynésie mais plutôt à savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut établir des
passerelles des passerelles entre
l'exécutif polynésien et les exigences
compréhensibles de sûreté du médicament
pour que cette médecine traditionnelle
s'est traduit praticien puisse trouver
leur place au sein de la République et
garder la place qui est à l'heure depuis
le fond des âges en Polynésie
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Robertson je comprends votre question et
de fait c'est vrai que la pharmacopée
pour une grande partie d'entre elles
relèvent de l'exploitation de plantes de
Racine issues de toute la planète je
ferai pas la liste ici de tous les
médicaments d'usage courant qui sont
directement issus l'exploitation des
plantes ils ont un point commun tous ces
médicaments issus des plantes c'est
qu'ils ont effectivement franchi des
étapes de validation scientifique sur
les effets positifs sur les effets
potentiels toxiques et donc délétères
avec des études qui permettent de
définir quelle est la dose précise de
telle molécules y compris ça l'issue des
plantes qui permet de guérir et éviter
par la même d'aggraver certaines
maladies
il en va ainsi dans le monde entier ce
qui veut pas dire qu'on ne veut pas se
poser les bonnes questions et qui n'est
pas question d'exploiter tout ce qui
peut l'être sur la planète y compris en
matière de plantes issues de Polynésie
française d'ailleurs vous savez que le
gouvernement est engagé pour pouvoir
favoriser l'exploitation scientifique de
toutes les ressources naturelles des
territoires ultramarins et d'ailleurs on
accompagne en cela les scientifiques les
laboratoires pour pouvoir le faire donc
si la question est de dire est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une reconnaissance
je dirais dérogatoire sans passer par
les fourches codines de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité de médicaments
pour reconnaître une plante comme un
médicament le simple intitulé de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament m'oblige à vous répondre non
en revanche il s'agit de savoir comment
vous aider à pouvoir faire reconnaître
au mieux les indications éventuelles de
tel ou telle plante dans tel ou tel
pathologie alors là écoutez c'est la
science fourmi d'idées et nous avons
encore une fois l'intention de pouvoir
accompagner l'exploitation de la flore
polynésienne
je vous remercie madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères
93 jours depuis 93 jours 120 000 hommes
femmes et enfants vivent littéralement
coupés du monde la tsar est devenue une
prison à ciel ouvert par la volonté de
la dictature azerbée janèse et
l'inaction délibérée des forces russes
chargées pourtant depuis 2020 de
garantir la sécurité de cette population
arménienne enclavée cette complicité a
été scellée deux jours avant l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine par un accord de
coopération renforcé entre alief et
Poutine sur le plan économique bancaire
militaire et énergétique et comme par
miracle Baku qui n'a pas trouvé de
nouveaux gisements depuis les années 90
signe en juillet un accord avec Ursula
vanderlione pour tripler ses
exportations de gaz avec l'Union
en novembre Bakou # carrément 3
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz à
Gazprom officiellement pour sa
consommation intérieure c'est donc bien
du gaz russe que l'Union européenne
achète à lazerbaïdjan du gaz russe pour
remplacer du gaz russe et pour financer
les canons pointés sur les Arméniens la
semaine dernière la situation
franchissait un nouveau palier avec
l'attaque menée par l'armée
azerbaïdjanes contre un véhicule en zone
arménienne faisant cinq morts dont trois
Arméniens et avec des menaces explicites
sur une prochaine opération militaire
madame la ministre l'heure est grave on
ne parle pas d'un conflit territorial ce
qui se passe depuis 93 jours dans une
relative indifférence est un drame
humanitaire et ce qui attend la star
c'est un nettoyage ethnique rendu
possible grâce à ses accords gaziers le
président de la République est tout à
fait conscient de la menace et que je
sais que notre diplomatie est pour
beaucoup dans le déploiement d'une
mission d'observation européenne à la
frontière arménienne mais la tsar se
meurt et il faut agir vite ou si je vous
demande et je crois pouvoir associer
toute la représentation nationale à ma
question quant allons-nous tirer les
conséquences de la décision de la Cour
internationale de justice en
fonctionnant les responsables de ce
blocus criminel et mettre un terme aux
accords gasiés conclu par la Commission
européenne qui alimente la complicité
entre Poutine et alliev je vous remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Tanzanie
le blocage du corridor de la Chine se
poursuit et vous savez combien cette
situation nous préoccupe également j'ai
dénoncé ici même le 28 février ce
blocage et les conséquences humanitaires
dramatiques qui sont suivent après le
grave évènement du 5 mars auquel vous
avez fait référence nous avons demandé
une enquête transparente et nous avons
également demandé que ces conclusions
soient rendues publiques nous souhaitons
par ailleurs que l'approvisionnement des
populations du haut-karaba soient
rétablies et que les négociations en
cours sur l'accès aux infrastructures
aboutissent dans ce cadre je vous
confirme que l'ordonnance de la cour
international de justice doit être
appliquée doit être immédiatement
appliqué et que la Cour ne manquera pas
d'en tenir compte dans sa décision au
fond qui va suivre cette décision en
référé tout comme l'Union européenne et
la communauté internationale par
l'intermédiaire des Nations Unies
pourront en tirer les conséquences
par ailleurs l'Union est extrêmement
attentive au risque de contournement des
sanctions visant la Russie et elle doit
encore renforcer sa vigilance nous y
travaillons n'en doutez pas madame la
députée la France est sans doute le pays
le plus engagé dans la défense des
Arméniens et avec l'Union européenne
avec les États-Unis nos contacts sont
permanents avec les deux pays Arménie et
Azerbaïdjan pour parvenir un accord de
paix et pour faire en sorte que les
populations du haut-karaba puissent
continuer d'y vivre dans le respect de
leur histoire de leur culture et de leur
dignité je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur David Topia pour le
groupe yote
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la santé savait colère que j'ai
appris au détour de la presse il y a
quelques jours la fermeture a très court
terme de la clinique de Gascogne située
dans le Gers en décembre dernier alors
que je vous ai interroge ici même à ce
sujet vous aviez pourtant pris
l'engagement de nous tenir au courant de
l'évolution du dossier
depuis pas de nouvelles new courrier que
je vous ai remis lors de votre visite
dans le Gers et pas davantage sur les
solutions envisagées par la RS et vos
services hors manifestement la mise en
place d'un protocole d'accord
partenarial assorti de critères
restreints et d'un délai trop courts ne
pouvait inévitablement mener un échec
programmé
de plus l'absence de réponse de l'ARS
aux demandes répétées du liquidateur
judiciaire n'a fait qu'accélérer le
processus aujourd'hui que proposez-vous
face à l'urgence de la situation
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement
monsieur le député
monsieur le député topiaque vous
interrogez le ministre de la Santé une
réunion européenne à Bruxelles encore
une fois je n'en excuse qui est pas de
confusion
au mois de janvier effectivement le
ministre de la Santé Jean Castex avait
été invité par le député Jean-René
Cazeneuve le ministre de la Santé
François Brown avait été invité avec
c'est gênant pardon
avait été convié par le député Jean-René
Cazeneuve sur le territoire gershwa pour
venir parler de l'accès aux soins et
l'organisation sanitaire entre hôpital
et clinique privée du territoire
monsieur député il semble
qu'effectivement la situation pour la
clinique soit compliquée elle a été
subventionnée elle a été aidé à bout de
bras par notamment par l'agence
régionale de santé il en est ressorti
que quel que soit l'issue je dirais quel
que soit l'organisation qui sera retenu
en définitive il y a un princeps un
principe que nous avons respecté il faut
que l'offre de soins notamment l'offre
de soins du parc hospitalier pour les
patients de ce territoire soit maintenu
en toute sécurité continuité et qualité
ainsi des propositions d'ores et déjà
été faites me semble-t-il par l'hôpital
mais aussi par des cliniques voisines au
corps médical pour pouvoir reprendre
l'organisation des soins sur ce
territoire en d'ailleurs en coordonnant
les choses et en consultant massivement
pourquoi pas via un conseil national de
la réfondation santé soyez assuré encore
une fois la détermination du
gouvernement et j'en parlais avec le
député Cazeneuve il y a pas longtemps
pour que nous puissions mettre en place
avec vous aussi monsieur le député
évidemment monsieur le député tobiac une
offre de soins acceptable et
satisfaisante
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Taupiac oui monsieur le
ministre vous ne prenez pas la mesure de
la situation l'urgence c'est de trouver
une solution pour éviter de faire perdre
au département 60% de son offre
chirurgical et le licenciement d'une
centaine de salariés l'urgence est de ne
plus avoir à annoncer à des patients
Athènes maladies graves la
déprogrammation d'opération vitale pour
eux comme c'est le cas depuis quelques
jours l'urgence est surtout que le
politique reprenne la main sur ce
dossier géré par une autorité
bureaucratique sur des logiques
comptables il est impératif de remettre
les acteurs autour de la table avec un
médiateur extérieur neutre et un
moratoire pour maintenir l'activité de
la clinique le temps de poursuivre
l'examen des solutions proposées 700 000
euros supplémentaires de son peut-être
pas un coup en tendable pour l'ARS mais
il n'est rien au regard d'un,5 à 2
millions d'euros annuels qui seront
nécessaires demain pour acheminer les
patients sur les centres de santé
voisins de Toulouse ou d'Agen en cas de
fermeture de la clinique
alors oui j'entends cette foi réelle
pilotage politique de votre ministère
pour éviter un désastre sanitaire pour
le Gers je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Muriel levreau
pour le groupe la princesse soumise
merci Madame la président monsieur le
ministre de la Santé chers collègues qui
auraient pu prédire la crise du système
hospitalier tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés ces dernières années
ont œuvré avec succès pour notre système
de santé publique
alors pourquoi les hôpitaux ne
subsistent qu'avec l'aide des
intérimaires qui choisissent de
travailler ainsi car ils peuvent alors
aménager leur temps de travail tout en
étant grassement rémunéré ce qui grève
les budgets des hôpitaux
partout en France de nombreuses
maternités sont menacées de fermeture
Guingamp car elle Andernos mais aussi
Gange hautain Porto-Vecchio Guéret le
rapport du docteur ville présenté
récemment à l'Académie de médecine
préconiserait la fermeture des 111
maternités qui ne pratiqueraient pas mis
l'accouchements par an à Guingamp on est
passé de 300 puis 500 à 1000
accouchements sans raison valable si ce
n'est de bâtir des usines à bébé mais
c'est une mise en danger d'autrui que
d'éloigner les femmes de l'accès aux
soins et c'est également une attente à
leur droit de disposer de leur corps que
de leur imposer des kilomètres pour
finir dans une chambre d'hôtel puis dans
une usine mais quel monde vous nous
imposez là
la loi risque qui vise à plafonner les
rémunérations des intérimaires adoptés
en 2021 a été repoussée parce qu'il
n'était pas possible à l'époque de
l'appliquer pourquoi serait-ce possible
3 avril prochain le principe est bon
mais qu'avez-vous fait depuis les
conditions à l'hôpital sont-elles plus
favorables aujourd'hui avez-vous
amélioré les conditions de travail et
les rémunérations des professionnels
dans les hôpitaux publics par rapport au
secteur privé avez-vous régulé
l'installateur l'installation des
médecins sur les territoires avez-vous
rétabli l'astreinte pour les nuits et
les week-ends l'application de cette loi
nécessaire nous inquiète au plus haut
point car elle menace l'existence de
nombreux services hospitaliers de
proximité monsieur le ministre
qu'avez-vous prévu pour que la loi
risque s'applique sans fermer les
hôpitaux des territoires ruraux et
s'enfermer nos maternités
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je ne m'attendais
pas nécessairement de la part d'une
députée de la France insoumise à
entendre
la défense d'une rémunération dans le
secteur public dépasserait les 1200
euros par jour
le plafonnement dont il est question
c'est un plafonnement à 1170 euros par
24 heures madame la député pour revoir
les chefs de valeur donc oui il faut
pouvoir l'appliquer et c'est nécessaire
pour assainir aussi la situation j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure
personne ne dit le difficulté qu'il y a
à recruter à conserver des médecins dans
les hôpitaux mais là excusez-moi quand
on parle de 1170 euros par jour vous
pouvez dire ça n'a rien à voir si si
parce que on va pas aligner une
rémunération dans le secteur public à
20000 euros par mois pour conserver des
médecins d'ailleurs c'est pas ce qu'ils
font de l'engagement des médecins dans
le cercle dans le secteur hospitalier et
je pense que vous pouvez être d'accord
là-dessus alors après vous faites un
mélange madame la députés avec un
rapport de l'Académie de médecine qui
est une autorité indépendante et qu'il
est donc pas un rapport gouvernemental
et qui propose d'augmenter le seuil
d'accouchement pour maintenir la qualité
la sécurité et la continuité des soins
dans une maternité à 1000 accouchement
il n'engage pas le gouvernement mais
nous en tenons compte pour pouvoir
engager une réflexion sur l'avenir du
système périnatal dans notre pays comme
nous le faisons régulièrement comme par
exemple lorsque nous avons revu à la
hausse les missions et les rémunérations
des sages-femmes dans notre pays comme
lorsque nous avons et ces sept majorité
qu'il a fait mis en place des maisons de
naissance pour aussi répondre à les
demandes des parturientes d'accoucher en
dehors des structures très médicalisées
madame la députée j'ai vraiment du mal
par contre mes oreilles saignent un peu
quand je vous entends parler d'usine à
bébé parce que vous pouvez avoir des qui
font 1500 2000 ou 3000 accouchements
sans parler d'usines c'est extrêmement
insultant laissez-moi le dire pour les
trois quarts des établissements de ce
pays et les trois quarts des femmes
françaises qui accouchent je crois pas
que les impressions d'accoucher dans des
usines à bébé députés ont parfois vous
voyez à force d'être excessifs dans la
parole et dans le verre pour essayer
d'attaquer systématiquement le
gouvernement même quand il n'est pas en
cause ni de près ni de loin et bien je
pense que vous tapez à côté je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Frédéric valtoux pour le
groupe horizon merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre chargée de la citoyenneté 22
ans après l'adoption la loi Abu Picard
je salue la volonté du gouvernement de
passer à la vitesse supérieure et de
redonner une impulsion pour lutter
contre le fléau des dérives sectaires ce
fut l'objet des premières Assises
Nationales des dérives sectaires qui ont
permis de poser la première pierre de la
future politique de lutte contre ces
mouvements oui l'action de l'État doit
s'adapter à l'évolution de ce phénomène
oui doit sévir face aux individus ou
plutôt charlatan qui souhaite profiter
des personnes fragiles isolées ou
malades l'annonce du gouvernement
vendredi dernier à l'issue de ses
assises d'encadrer les pratiques de
soins non conventionnels comme l'année
la naturopathie la lipolyse ou les
médecines énergétiques qui prolifèrent
depuis la crise sanitaire est une bonne
nouvelle et je m'en réjouis la santé est
toujours une porte d'entrée des dérives
sectaires et un moyen pour de nombreux
mouvements d'attirer de nouveaux adeptes
dans son dernier rapport la mividude des
nombres dans le pays près de 4000
psychothérapeutes autoproclamés
c'est-à-dire n'ayant suivi aucune
formation et n'étant inscrit sur aucun
registre prétextant l'inutilité des
traitements conventionnels le pseudo
praticien va demander aux patients
d'avoir toute confiance en lui car il
affirme être le seul à détenir la
méthode miracle apte à guérir n'importe
qui adolescent personne fragile en
situation de précarité ou fragilisée par
une maladie peut-être un si victime d'un
pseudothérapeute à l'heure où notre
système de santé connaît déjà une crise
profonde ne rajoutons pas à cela une
profusion de ces dérives qui
brouilleraient encore plus l'accès aux
soins pour nos concitoyens aussi madame
la ministre j'ai une question
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles
mesures précis seront prises pour lutter
contre les dérives sectaires dans le
domaine de la santé et notamment contre
ces pratiques de soins
non-conventionnels merci beaucoup je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté
merci à la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Valtou d'abord je vous remercie de votre
participation à ces assises des dérives
sectaires comme un certain nombre de
députés des différents groupes pardon
qui composent cette assemblée c'était un
moment historique et important suite à
l'explosion constatée des signalements
en matière de dérive sectaire avec
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
concernées par ces dérives et donc
c'était important qu'on puisse se
retrouver votre question concerne en
particulier le domaine de la santé et
effectivement c'est le domaine dans
lequel l'explosion des signalements et
la plus importante et c'est un des
domaines sur lesquels nous avons eu les
propositions les plus fortes première
proposition et vous l'avez évoqué celle
qui a été annoncé par la ministre
délégué auprès du ministre de la Santé
Agnès Firmin le Baudeau annonçant
l'encadrement des des pratiques de non
conventionnelles de soins que vous avez
cité en particulier qui est
effectivement vont permettre tout
simplement aux Français de savoir si ils
peuvent aller voir un praticien en
confiance ou non mais un certain nombre
de propositions également été faites en
matière de santé notamment
l'interdiction de la publicité de ces
pratiques non conventionnelles de soins
pour les maladies graves la mise en
place d'un délit d'incitation à l'arrêt
du traitement médical et puis la
possibilité éventuelle pour les ARS
d'interdire d'exercer pour les
thérapeutes déviants ces propositions en
matière de santé s'inscrivent dans un
plan plus global qui se rapportait par
la mi-vilud dont les moyens vont être
augmentés de 25% et qui vont concerner à
la fois la prévention puisque nous avons
besoin d'alerter les français pour
qu'ils évitent de rentrer dans ces
dérives aussi facilement qu'ils le font
aujourd'hui avec un gros travail qui va
être mené avec avec les plateformes de
réseaux sociaux un travail de
communication également un travail
également sur les victimes qu'il nous
faudra d'une part accompagner traiter
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
aujourd'hui la mivilud c'est
effectivement un endroit centralisé mais
l'idée c'est que on puisse les traiter
sur le tout le territoire merci beaucoup
je vous remercie madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel Bléry pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à Monsieur Marc feno ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est un peu la diversaire
français du sucre de betterave puisqu'il
y a 212 ans quasiment jour pour jour
Napoléon a pulsé une politique pour son
développement en 2023 la France est
premier producteur en Europe mais
jusqu'à quand la situation dans laquelle
se retrouve nos betteraviers est grave
alors qu'en 2013 la Commission
européenne annonce la suspension de
certaines substances insecticides le
gouvernement socialiste de l'époque dont
faisait partie Emmanuel Macron fait du
zèle en accentuant les règles
européennes je vais vous dire Monsieur
le Ministre on en peut plus de ces
décisions dogmatiques donc on découvre
pas pardon chaque jour et on subit
aujourd'hui les conséquences il y a eu
des erreurs et des choix énergétiques et
sur l'abandon du nucléaire maintenant
c'est la filière agricole qui en est
frappé la réponse du gouvernement un
énième plan et qui dit plan dit pas de
solution
et nous voyons apparaître des effets
désastreux pouvant se rapporter à ces
décisions en effet Tereos annonce fermé
la sucrerie des codes dans le Cambrésis
moyennant la suppression de 123 postes
outrera ladite substance reste pourtant
autorisée une nouvelle fois encore en
assiste impuissant au déclin français
pour le plus grand bénéfice du voisin
allemand le groupe rassemblement
national est prêt à le cohérence
collective mais jamais au détriment des
Français notre souveraineté doit être un
absolu dans nos notre concorde nationale
gouverner c'est prévoir alors ma
question est la suivante outre ce plan
d'une vision à court terme quelle mesure
pérenne comptez-vous prendre pour
permettre aux producteurs de betteraves
de consolider la filière et les employés
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
présidente madame mesdames messieurs les
députés monsieur le député Blairy comme
toujours quand il s'agit d'évoquer des
problèmes vous êtes présent quand il
s'agit d'évoquer des solutions vous
manquez à l'appel je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'étais dans le Territoire du
Nord pour justement évoquer la fermeture
potentielle contre laquelle je me bats
une usine Tereos contre laquelle
l'ensemble des députés des élus du
département se battent à l'opposé
évidemment de des députés du Front
national qui manquait à l'appel hier
alors qu'on discutait de l'emploi dans
vos territoires alors une fois de plus
évidemment vous criez vous criez mais
quand il s'agit de trouver des solutions
quand il s'agit de mettre la pression
sur les entreprises pour que plutôt que
de fermer des usines alors qu'elle gagne
de l'argent on les incite à fédérer la
filière à travailler avec les
producteurs de betteraves pour que les
semences soient plus élevés pour que la
production soit plus élevée là encore
vous manquez à l'appel moi je souhaite
et pour avoir été président de la
Commission des affaires économiques qui
a voté les exemptions qui ont permis aux
producteurs de betteraves de continuer
leur production que nous soutenons la
filière mais je souhaite que celles et
ceux qui sont impliqués dans cette
filière qui aujourd'hui profitent de
prix du sucre particulièrement élevé qui
profite d'un marché en pleine expansion
joue aussi le rôle prennent aussi leur
responsabilité de manière à ce que
l'ensemble de la filière puisse être
gagnante
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député oui merci Madame
présidente si rien n'est fait monsieur
le ministre au-delà du blabla c'est tout
un savoir-faire qui risque de
disparaître en réalité on ira chercher
notre sucre en Allemagne en Amérique
latine et sans parler évidemment des
conséquences en matière de carbone à
quand le retour du bon sens paysan c'est
ça c'est la vraie question comme on dit
chez moi vous êtes des prometteux de
bonjour Merci
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal le coin
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues la question s'adresse aux
ministres d'économie et des Finances
Bruno Le Maire Monsieur le Ministre
vendredi dernier la Silicon Valley Bank
16e banque américaine d'actifs a fait
faillite cette défaillance est la plus
importante depuis la grande récession de
2009 à cela s'ajoute celle de la
signature banque 21e banque américaine
et la silvergate Bank spécialisée en
crypto monnaie je vous remercie pour
votre première réponse tout à l'heure
rassurant sur la question de la solidité
de notre système bancaire nous avons
depuis 2008 rue fortement le cadre
prudentiel révision des accords de
balles sur les niveaux de fonds propres
création d'un mécanisme pour prévenir le
risque de liquidité ou encore meilleur
encadrement des activités de marché qui
doivent ainsi conforter la résilience de
nos banques à l'échelle européenne la
première phase de l'Union bancaire
entièrement revu notre système de
supervision le rendant plus sûr est plus
efficace que celui des États-Unis
toutefois des inquiétudes subsistent les
différents marchés financiers ont depuis
lundi fortement vacillés moi 4% pour la
BNP moins 6% pour la Société Générale à
la clôture hier soir plusieurs voix se
sont élevées pour nous alerter du risque
d'une nouvelle crise financière mondiale
faisant craindre de revivre le cauchemar
de 2009 2012 monsieur le ministre cette
faillite n'est-elle pas une piqûre de
rappel quant à la nécessité d'achever
enfin l'Union bancaire et de mettre en
place une véritable garantie européenne
des dépôts de protéger mieux nos
concitoyens sans risquer de fragiliser
les finances publiques de chacun de ces
États membres je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon chers collègues la parole
est à Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député Pascal Lecan je crois
qu'il y a une leçon à retenir de cette
faillite de la banque régionale
américaine c'est que prudence émer de
toutes les vertus en particulier en
matière bancaire qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans le cas de la SVB la SVB
s'exposait un seul secteur la tech elle
l'a fait sur des bons du trésor sans que
les règles balles 3 s'appliquent
totalement à cette banque régionale
américaine c'est la décision prise par
le président américain Donald Trump en
2019 qui a exonéré les banques
régionales américaines d'un certain
nombre d'obligations de balles 3
notamment en cas de moins-value latente
ce qui était le cas sur la base des bons
du Trésor américain les moins values de
la tente étaient de plus en plus
évidentes puisque les taux d'intérêts
augmentaient et que ces banques avaient
placées sur des taux d'intérêt à taux
fixe et très bas les moins values
d'attente et de plus en plus évidentes
avec balle 3 vous avez une obligation
d'avoir une solvabilité plus forte et
des placements en capitaux ce qu'il faut
cette banque n'était pas soumise à cette
obligation d'où la faillite à laquelle
nous assistons aujourd'hui dont nous
sommes protégés par le mécanisme de
supervision européen nous avons mis en
place depuis plus de 6 ans le mécanisme
européen de supervision une supervision
européenne le fond de résolution unique
à 75 milliards d'euros nous avons donc
renforcé les dispositifs de supervision
européen le mécanisme européen est plus
puissant plus solide plus protecteur que
le mécanisme de supervision retenu par
les États-Unis je partage totalement
votre avis il faut continuer dans cette
direction là s'attaquer maintenant la
mise en place d'une véritable union
bancaire qui ne touche pas que la
supervision mais également les
mécanismes de dépôt nous y travaillons
et j'espère que nous parviendrons un
résultat dans les mois qui viennent
[Musique]
je vais voir le groupe écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de la transition énergétique
nous avons découvert par communiqué du 8
février dernier la décision du
gouvernement de réunir les compétences
techniques de l'IRSN et de la SN l'OPEX
par ces deux présidents que l'on peut
remercier c'est saisi du sujet à
l'organisant une audition publique le 16
février à laquelle était convié le
président de la SN le directeur général
de l'IRSN l'administrateur général du
CEA le directeur recherche et
développement du Groupe EDF la
directrice sûreté Sécurité Environnement
du groupe ohano mais également le
directeur de l'ANCLI un chercheur
émérite et un ancien député LR fait
résident de l'Office les approches
étaient pour le moins différenciées l'un
plaidant pour la réforme d'autres
indiquant qu'elle se conformeraient
tandis que d'autres encore se sont
exprimés en faveur de la préservation du
système actuel je n'en citerai que deux
l'ancien président de l'OPEX Claude
Birot estimait que l'organisation prévue
traduit je cite une méconnaissance grave
de l'organisation de la sûreté et quand
danger serait en retour en arrière de 30
ans Michael mangeons chercheur concluait
son intervention en indiquant que ce
projet risquerait d'affaiblir la
légitimité du système de sécurité auprès
des citoyens à la fin lopex est resté
dans l'interrogation qui était la sienne
avant les auditions à savoir pourquoi
cette réforme et pourquoi si vite et du
coup deux questions ma question la
première est simple pourquoi mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs pourquoi ne pas
faire précéder cette réforme d'une phase
de diagnostic et d'études d'impact suivi
d'une phase de négociation deuxième
question dans l'hypothèse où vous ne
reviendriez pas sur votre décision quels
sont vos options si les rapports
commandés à la SN et l'IRSN remettait en
cause votre projet eu égard aux
multiples réserves déjà exprimées
merci ma chère collègues la parole est à
Madame Agnès panier rue naché ministre
de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
à Reiki je vais remettre cette réforme
de la sûreté nucléaire dans son contexte
plus général comme vous le savez le
grand combat de ce siècle le grand
combat que nous menons au niveau du
gouvernement c'est de sortir notre pays
des énergies fossiles et pour sortir
notre pays des énergies fossiles il y a
deux possibilités de levier baisser
notre consommation d'énergie nous y
travaillons avec la sobriété énergétique
et l'efficacité énergétique et produire
plus de l'extérité bas carbone produire
plus d'électricité par carbone c'est
plus d'énergie renouvelable au passage
un projet de loi que vous n'avez pas
voté et c'est produire aussi plus de
nucléaires et faire face au remplacement
de nos réacteurs nucléaires qui
arriveront un jour à leur terme à l'aune
et au début madame la hernes si vous
aviez la gentillesse de me laisser
parler merci à l'aube du lancement d'un
des grands d'un des plus grands
programmes de réacteurs nucléaires que
nous sommes en train de faire nous
sommes en train de fortifier l'ensemble
des briques technologiques de la filière
nucléaire et une de ces briques c'est la
sûreté nucléaire c'est ce qui nous amène
effectivement à regrouper l'efforts de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et de
l'IRSN alors que s'agit-il de quoi
s'agit-il de réunir les forces sous une
même bannière d'autorité administrative
indépendante de ces deux organismes pour
être enfin au niveau des grandes
organisations qui assure la sûreté
nucléaire dans les autres pays qui ont
des grands programmes nucléaires est-ce
que vous savez qu'aujourd'hui la France
est une à une des autorités de sûreté
nucléaire qui a le plus faible nombre de
d'employés est-ce que vous savez ça en
quoi est-il problématique de réunir
enfin sur cette dernière d'autorité
administrative indépendante l'ensemble
des efforts au service de cette ambition
nucléaire et je vais être très clair ici
l'expertise la recherche seront
évidemment
préservés ce que fait le projet de loi
c'est simplement d'élargir les missions
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire de
sécuriser le parcours des agents de
l'URSS sans changer une ligne de notre
droit
merci beaucoup madame reggae je note que
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
que ferez-vous si à l'issue du rapport
que vous avez demandé à la SN à l'IRSN
il était indiqué que au regard des
multiples réserves déjà exprimés la
réunion ou l'absorption de l'URSS par la
SN n'était pas du tout une bonne idée
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question la
parole est à madame Isabelle Santiago
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre des Solidarités aujourd'hui en
France plus d'un enfant sur cinq vit en
situation de pauvreté nous n'avons
jamais connu une aggravation aussi
rapide de la précarité les indicateurs
de grande pauvreté sont au rouge et
doivent tous nous alerter en décembre
dernier on comptabilisé plus de 1300
enfants sans solution d'hébergement un
record tristement historique le dernier
rapport de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
montre que les enfants qui vivent dans
les logements à salubes se comptent par
centaines de milliers concernant
l'alimentation on observe une hausse de
plus de 30%. des bébés inscrits à l'aide
alimentaire en Île-de-France des Restos
du coeur pour la campagne hiver 2023 il
y a aujourd'hui en France 110 000 bébés
pris en charge par les Restos du coeur
alors à l'heure où la campagne vient de
se finir ce vendredi dernier que
vont-ils devenir quelle réponse nous
apportons à cette urgence avec
l'inflation qui s'aggrave en mars qui
est déjà à un très haut niveau si on
regarde le nombre de bénéficiaires dont
les enfants de moins de 5 ans sur
l'ensemble des grandes associations
caritatives à l'échelle nationale
il y a de quoi être en urgence absolue
de répondre à ce défi de bien grandir
mais la grande pauvreté des enfants
n'est pas une fertilité la politique
c'est un art du possible c'est de voir
trouver des solutions sur un plan
ambitieux en 2021 lors de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne les
États membres ont adopté une garantie
européenne pour l'enfance visant à
lutter contre la pauvreté des enfants
j'appelle solennellement le gouvernement
à la prendre véritablement en compte à
appliquer les recommandations c'était
l'objet de notre tribune signé avec la
présidente de l'UNICEF ce dimanche
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Isabelle Santiago j'ai reçu il y a
quelques jours la présidente Azan
présidente de l'Unicef France pour faire
le point effectivement sur la situation
et je dois vous dire que je rejoins un
certain nombre de vos constats que nous
que nous partageons notamment le fait
que dans notre pays un trop grand nombre
d'enfants aujourd'hui sont victimes de
pauvreté et d'exclusion sociale je
voudrais rappeler aussi que ces
dernières années l'action du
gouvernement a été puissante et résolu
pour réduire la pauvreté des enfants
dans notre pays et c'est ce qui a permis
notamment pendant la crise sanitaire
d'éviter une explosion de la pauvreté et
de maintenir un taux de pauvreté et une
progression à un taux relativement
stable bien évidemment il nous faut
continuer à agir et c'est d'ailleurs le
constat que la pauvreté dans notre pays
fait face à un déterminisme important
que nous avons construit le plan de
lutte contre la pauvreté 2018
2000-2022 et construit un de mesure
notamment pour répondre à la pauvreté
des enfants ça a été le cas avec par
exemple dédoublement des classes de CP
CE1 dans les zones éducation
prioritaires ça a été le cas également
avec le bonus pour assurer les mixité
sociale dans nos crèches ça a été le cas
aussi avec les subventions du
gouvernement aux collectivités pour
assurer une tarification sociale de la
cantine les repas à 1 euro les petits
déjeuners gratuits dans les écoles pour
permettre aux enfants d'accéder à une
alimentation plus équilibrée pour autant
on va pas s'arrêter là je vais présenter
dans quelques semaines un pacte des
solidarités qui a été construit avec mes
collègues du gouvernement pour répondre
à cette question dans toutes ces
dimensions impact qui permettra de
répondre à ces problématiques il faudra
poursuivre le travail d'accès à une
alimentation de qualité également
prévenir les inégalités sociales de
santé et le décrochage scolaire ou
encore garantir l'accès à des temps
libres favorisant l'épanouissement des
enfants il me semble que c'est
extrêmement important et nous le
porterons aussi au niveau européen et je
vous rappelle que la France a été l'un
des premiers pays à mettre en œuvre la
garantie européenne pour l'enfance
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe juin
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente cette question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie
ce ministre je voudrais revenir sur
cette question très grave de la faillite
de la Silicon valley-banque cette
faillite ce n'est pas un accident c'est
la crise d'un système dans lequel nous
avons tous vécu au plan mondial celui de
l'argent soit disant gratuit c'est aussi
le signe que toutes les banques qu'elle
soit petite ou grande en fait ont des
effets systémiques et qu'elles doivent à
ce titre être regardés comme ayant des
effets systémiques sur toutes les
économie quel que soit leur taille par
le régulateur vous avez raison de dire
que les banques françaises sont beaucoup
mieux protégées c'est une réalité depuis
2008 le législateur national et européen
à multiplier les règles prudentielles
qui font qu'aujourd'hui les ratios de
solvabilité de liquidité
les garanties pour les Parisiens sont
plus importantes en Europe en France en
particulier qu'aux États-Unis toutefois
il y a peut-être des des trous dans la
raquette européenne en particulier quand
il y a eu les débats au Parlement et au
Conseil européen les banques régionales
allemandes essentiellement mais aussi
espagnol italienne ont échappé pour une
partie au régulation très dur qui sont
imposées aux banques françaises et donc
là dessus c'est rajouter depuis 10 ans
une fragmentation immense du marché les
états faisant l'implémentation de la
réglementation un peu à leur sauce et
tout ça fait qu'il y a une complexité
d'application très importante qui était
soulevée par la Cour des comptes
européennes récemment donc la question
c'est est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer
demander à la Commission européenne un
stress test de toutes les banques en
particulier des banques régionales en
fait enfin votre premier arme monsieur
Miss c'est la confiance alors dans cette
optique seriez-vous prêt aussi à étudier
l'augmentation du seuil de garantie des
dépôts bancaires des épargnants et à ce
titre il faudrait évidemment demander à
ce que l'abondement du fonds de
résolution unique qui est la Caisse de
garantie des épargnants soit repoussés
au-delà de 2023 comme vous le savez à la
fin 2023 le fonds de résolution unique
en théorie doit cesser d'être abondé il
faut probablement la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des
je crois monsieur le député juin je
partage votre analyse mais je crois
vraiment que les Européens ont tiré
toutes les leçons de la crise financière
de 2008 pour renforcer la protection du
système bancaire et des banques
européennes en particulier des banques
françaises et que nous avons désormais
une protection qui est solide je le
redis avec beaucoup de gravité il n'y a
pas de risque sur les bancs françaises
il n'y a pas de risque sur le système
bancaire français je veux le dire à tous
les notes parvient à tous les
entrepreneurs qui ont déposé leurs fonds
auprès des banques françaises s'agissant
du montant des fonds propres je rappelle
que le montant des fonds propres qui ont
été exigés des banques françaises à
doubler à 550 milliards d'euros depuis
la crise de 2008 pour renforcer le ratio
de solvabilité des banques françaises et
ce ratio de solvabilité il existe pour
les banques françaises il existe pour
les banques européennes je rappelle
qu'ils ne s'appliquent pas aux banques
régionales américaines le ratio de
liquidité ne s'applique pas non plus aux
banques régionales américaines ce qui
fait que lorsqu'elle place sur un
mauvais placement et qu'il y a des
pertes d'attentes et ben il n'y a pas de
liquidité en face il n'y a pas de
collatéral qui protège les dépôts des
épargnants ou les dépôts des
entrepreneurs ensuite est-ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin sur les mécanismes
européens la réponse est oui et je pense
que nous avons tout intérêt à renforcer
encore l'Union bancaire nous l'avons
fait avec les mécanismes de ces
pervisions uniques c'était déjà un
premier progrès le fond de résolution
unique 75 milliards d'euros c'est un
deuxième progrès attention de que à
chaque fois la France participe et paye
aussi pour se fondre résolution unique
donc pas forcément intérêt à trop
augmenter les exigences en capital ou
les exigences sur le fond de résolution
unique en revanche qu'il y ait des
systèmes de résolution en cas de crise
bancaire qui soit des systèmes uniques
valables pour toutes les banques
européennes ça nous y sommes extrêmement
favorables pour que ce soit d'abord les
actionnaires qui payent en cas de
défaillance les banques qui payent en
cas de défa illance et pas le
contribuable c'est ça la prochaine étape
de l'Union bancaire et croyez-moi nous
sommes très déterminés à l'affaire
aboutir
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Françoise buffet
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
depuis vendredi avant de panique s'est
emparé des marchés boursiers l'acide
licorne Valley banque a fait faillite
une première depuis la crise financière
de 2008 cette banque spécialisée dans le
financement des start-ups du numérique
semblaient pourtant solide avec 209
milliards de dollars d'actifs pour
environ 175 milliards de dépôts au 31
décembre 2022 elle n'est cependant pas
parvenue à faire face au retrait massif
de ses principaux clients la hausse
vigoureuse des taux directeurs des
banques centrales imposées par la forte
inflation en effet eu un double effet
préjudiciable d'un côté les entreprises
technologiques se sont retrouvés
incapables de lever des fonds et ont
donc puisé dans leur liquidité d'un
autre les obligations qui constituaient
une part importante des actifs de CVB
ont été dépréciés au moment même où la
banque a dû les vendre pour répondre aux
besoins de cash de ses clients SVB dans
sa chute deux autres institutions
bancaires américaines la crainte d'une
propagation systémique et réelle comme
un témoigne l'effondrement des cours
hier en clôture la Bourse de Paris a
perdu 2,9% celle de Frankfort 3,04 % et
celle de Londres
2,58%. les valeurs bancaires européennes
ont amplifié leur chute en deux séances
l'indice de référence des banques
européennes côté a chuté de 10,2%. face
à cette situation la secrétaire
américaine au Trésor a indiqué tout
mettre en oeuvre afin d'éviter que c'est
faillites ne se propage restent du
système bancaire garantissant notamment
l'intégralité des dépôts la Fed c'est
également engagée à prêter les fonds
nécessaires à d'autres banques qui en
auraient besoin pour honorer les
demandes de retrait de leurs clients
conscient de l'inquiétude ambiante vous
avez réagi par un appel au calme avant
une réunion des ministres des Finances
de la zone euro à Bruxelles alors que
vous rentrez de votre déplacement à
Bruxelles au cours duquel vous avez
changé ma chère collègues monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
buffet la preuve que nos appels au calme
ont été entendus c'est que la Bourse de
Paris aujourd'hui c'est redressée alors
qu'elle avait accusé une forte chute
hier
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens des
ministres des Finances européens ont
rappelé qu'il n'y avait pas de crainte à
avoir sur le système bancaire européen
et pour ceux qui me concerne
c'est-à-dire le système bancaire
français je redis que nous n'avons pas
d'inquiétude à avoir qui n'a pas de
risque sur les banques françaises à
titre de précaution j'ai réuni ce matin
l'ensemble des dirigeants des banques
françaises et le gouverneur de la Banque
de France pour faire un point avec eux
sur la situation le superviseur le
gouverneur de la Banque de France m'a
confirmé que nous n'avions pas de risque
sur les banques françaises et qui n'est
pas de risque non plus sur le
financement de l'économie française
c'était un des points que je voulais
voir avec les présidents des grandes
bandes françaises soit la BNP le Crédit
Agricole la banque postale ou toutes les
autres grandes banques universelles
françaises il n'y a pas de risque sur le
financement de l'économie française sur
le financement latex françaises ou sur
le financement plus global de notre
économie nous continuerons à suivre de
très près l'évolution de la situation
mais les préoccupations elles portent
plus sur les États-Unis que sur l'Europe
par ailleurs la réponse qui était
apportée par les États-Unis était une
réponse immédiate une réponse forte nous
verrons si cette réponse suffit à
circonscrire la situation aux États-Unis
je le souhaite mais nous ne voyons ni
risques sur les banques françaises ni
risque de contagion à la situation
européenne
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Madame Christine en grand pour le
rassemblement national merci Madame la
Ministre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique chers collègues en 2021 la
loi climat est résilience était
promulgué objectif en passage la fin de
tout artifice des sols à l'horizon 2050
utopique le principe drague derrière lui
son lot de paradoxe et s'oppose
frontalement aux aspirations
pavillonnaires de la majorité des
Français un sondage mené par l'Ifop en
janvier 2022 relève en effet que 80% de
nos concitoyens souhaitent à terme vivre
dans une maison avec un jardin à ce
désir d'horizontalité vous opposez
jusque dans le choix du logement la
verticalité brute et froide de votre
gouvernement peu importe si l'Insee
conseille de produire 300 à 400 000
logements d'ici 2030 un rapport du Sénat
démontre que votre objectif ampute la
production annuelle de 90 000 nouveaux
logements peu importe si selon les
outils de mesure choisie
l'artificialisation en France varie de
16000 61 000 hectares par an et ces
France de stratégie qui le dit peu
importe si cet objectif par une
raréfaction des espaces disponibles
menacent d'alourdir gravement les
charges foncières et donc de faire
obstacle à l'accès à la propriété pour
les moins riches peu importe si vous
avez instauré un climat d'inquiétude
foncièrement délétère chez les élus qui
sont à la fois incitées et attirés de
nouveaux habitants pour alimenter les
caisses de la commune et en même temps
décourager de construire pour préserver
les sols en effet naviguant à vue de
nombreux intercommunalités rurales
poussent les communes à construire dès
maintenant où il reste de la place des
villages de moins de 300 habitants comme
celui de leulant dans Max circo sont
incités à supporter l'ajout de 15
hectares à une zone d'activités en
comptant déjà 50 au détriment des terres
agricoles que vous prétendez protéger et
contre la vie des habitants à l'inverse
certaines communes devront faire une
croix sur des services essentiels exit
les maisons médicales et les nouvelles
écoles infinies l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation nette ne peut conduire
que dépérissement de notre économie et
de notre démocratie ou se renier en
lui-même à la création de de dérogations
à nos plus finir tel que le suggère le
texte proposé aujourd'hui au Sénat en
définitive entre la décroissance de la
France où le renoncement à ce projet
fantasmagorique que faites-vous au
niveau du gouvernement merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Dominique fort ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée en grand avec Christophe Béchu
nous sommes au travail depuis juillet
2022 pour travailler sur cet objectif à
2050 que nous pose la loi climat et
résilience en matière de 0
artificialisation net nous en sommes
heureux et fiers nous sommes au travail
en fait personne personne pas même les
collectivités locales que vous citez ne
remet en cause cet enjeu essentiel de
lutte contre l'artificialisation des
sols cette lutte qui doit être bien sûr
acceptable et soutenable mais cet enjeu
personne personne ne le met en cause
nous en sommes fiers comme je vous le
disais nous travaillons depuis juillet
avec les associations d'élus avec les
départements avec les parlementaires
pour travailler sur des ajustements pour
travailler sur des évolutions pour la
rendre acceptable comme je vous le
disais nous sommes d'accord pour amender
légèrement ce dispositif nous avons
abordé ces discussions depuis l'été 2022
dans un esprit d'ouverture nous avons
que plusieurs choses à la fois la
nécessité de se donner du temps pour
co-construire ces documents d'urbanisme
nous avons entendu la nécessité que nous
demandait les territoires ruraux de
donner une capacité minimale de
développement c'est la garantie rurale
nous sommes en train d'y travailler pas
plus tard qu'aujourd'hui si j'excuse
aujourd'hui Christophe Béchu c'est parce
qu'il est au Sénat en train Auban et
emprunt de répondre à cette PPL du
sénateur blanc et puis je vous disais
aussi que nous avons entendu ce besoin
de décompter à part les projets
d'envergure national et européennes
toutes ces demandes tous ces enjeux tous
ces débats au Sénat dans le cas de la
PPL du sénateur blanc aujourd'hui le 14
mars alors oui vous voulez parler de
brutalité froides oui vous voulez parler
de communes qui doivent mettre une croix
sur les services essentiels j'en suis à
ma 53e visite dans nos territoires dans
nos départements depuis l'été et je
rassure j'écoute nous prenons en compte
et je vous assure que je suis sûr
qu'après ces travaux et des bas nous
concilierons les enjeux de la transition
écologique qui traversent notre société
et les préoccupations légitimes de nos
élus de nos territoires merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Arnaud Le Gall pour le groupe
la France insoumise
ma ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre jeudi dernier la
Silicon valley-banque affiché 210
milliards de dollars d'actifs s'effondré
il s'agit de la deuxième plus grosse
faillite bancaire de l'histoire des
États-Unis pour déclarations sur lequel
il n'y aurait pas de lien entre la
situation aux États-Unis et celle en
Europe n'ont pas empêché la baisse du
CAC 40 en raison notamment des chutes
des actions de la BNP de la Société
Générale le capitalisme financiarisé de
repose d'abord sur une confiance très
aléatoire dans ce système fou pourquoi
les joueurs de casino ferraient-ils
confiance à l'un des croupiers quand
tous les ingrédients d'une crise sont
réunis les acteurs qui donnent le las
sur les marchés financiers savent que
les politiques appliquées en Europe et
notamment en France sont similaires à
celle ayant mené à cette situation aux
États-Unis car au-delà des différences
de réglementations bancaires que vous
avez les souligner la faillite comme
Valley banque trouve d'abord ses
origines dans le déversement massif
d'argent gratuit pendant la pandémie
comme ce déversement n'a pas été
conditionné à l'investissement dans
l'économie productive il a alimenté des
bulles financières celle-ci menacent
désormais de se dégonfler avec perte et
fracas en raison du choix des banques
centrales de remonter taux d'intérêt
pour soi-disant lutter contre
l'inflation pourtant comme le FMI
lui-même l'inflation actuelle ne vient
pas d'une boucle salaire prime et d'une
boucle pénurie profit l'objectif réel de
la hausse des taux est d'exercer une
pression à la baisse sur les salaires
afin d'augmenter les marges des
entreprises et de préserver la
rémunération des actionnaires mais voilà
faire payer au plus pauvre l'inflation
menace désormais de provoquer une
nouvelle crise dans les effets seraient
incommensurables sur notre économie il
est urgent de changer de politique
économique et monétaire mènerez-vous le
bras de fer pour que la Banque centrale
européenne agit sans ce sens allez-vous
tôt ou tard conditionner les aides aux
entreprises notamment bancaires à
l'investissement dans l'économie
l'économie productive enfin ne
voyez-vous pas le monsieur le ministre
dans le cataclysme qui se menace une
nouvelle raison d'abandonner une réforme
des retraites qui crée réellement encore
plus de chômage merci
[Applaudissements]
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'économie et
des finances
[Musique]
mais je n'ai pas interrompu la
présidente
je voulais terminer votre question que
nous sommes partis de la Silicon
valley-ban pour aller jusqu'à Banque
centrale européenne et finir par
l'inflation et la réforme des retraites
je veux dire que vous avez parcouru un
chemin qui est assez vaste et je suis
surpris de votre fascination pour les
États-Unis d'Amérique je rappelle que le
système américain n'a rien à voir avec
le système européen nous nous défendons
le système européen parce qu'il est plus
protecteur qu'il évite qu'on joue au
casino avec les économies de nos
compatriotes qu'il repose sur une base
d'actifs qui est très diversifiée alors
que la SVB était exposé uniquement aux
valeurs de la tech que nous exigeons à
chaque fois qu'il y ait du capital qu'en
contrepartie des risques qui sont pris
par les banques que nous refusons que
les banques soient exposées à un seul
type d'actifs alors que le SVB n'était
exposé qu'à un seul type d'actifs et
donc un risque d'écart de taux qui a
provoqué la faillite de cette banque
nous avons un système protecteur en
Europe monsieur Trump a fait le choix
parce que c'est lui qui a fait ce choix
là de ne pas étendre le système de
supervision bancaire aux banques
régionales américaine vous défendez les
choix fait par Monsieur Trump nous
défendons les choix fait par l'Europe et
la Banque centrale européenne
je vous remercie allez-y mon cher
collègue
les Français verront le moment venu la
valeur de votre réponse caricaturale
je vous remercie la séance suspendue
[Applaudissements]